the battlefield
[Music]
flank your foes
and find opportunities to thwart them
adapt and use all the tools at your
disposal
including your enemies
[Music]
each hero is equipped with a specific
weapon
from handy double shots
to flashy explosive projectiles to
dazzling melee attacks
they all offer complimentary play styles
once the heroes finish their turn it's
time for the enemies to step up
make sure to take cover to avoid attacks
because your foes won't miss an
opportunity to take aim at your heroes
each of our heroes has a unique
technique
shield your allies in battle
prepare a devastating counter-attack
or put your enemies to sleep
techniques will always prove useful if
used in the right context
each battle one will grant experience
points to the team and the heroes will
level up allowing them to grow more
powerful
in an intense battle mario and his
friends can count on the help of the
sparks
each hero can harness their powers in
battle
sparks open a whole world of tactical
possibilities
clever use of their abilities can truly
make the difference between defeat
and victory
[Music]
teamwork is key to gaining the upper
hand
use all the tools at your disposal to
set up devastating combos and win
difficult battles
this was just a glimpse of the journey
that awaits mario and his friends
where the end of a quest is always the
beginning of a new adventure
meet enchanting and enduring characters
face powerful enemies during epic
encounters
[Music]
find the sparks and save them from cursa
[Music]
embark on this great adventure
for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope is
coming to switch this fall bringing back
beloved heroes and teaming them up with
new allies including a very unexpected
one
to learn more about bowser joining our
heroes a couple of the planets your team
will explore and using new powers and
techniques in battle we spoke to lead
producer xavier manzanares
what were some of the first thoughts
when you started thinking about new
characters to bring to sparks of hope
you don't want to
to add random characters to the cast but
think in a way that how would they
impact the battles
edge um
the the new rabbit hero for instance
is all about close quarter combat and
reacting to the enemy's mid and close
range
and she has tons of personality too so
we're excited also because we saw bowser
is joining our heroes how did the idea
to make bowser and ally come about so we
wanted to add a nintendo character that
would be
surprising for the players so having
mario and bowser in the same team
is quite unique we truly love the idea
of having bowser as well in a tactical
game bowser fits perfectly the combo
needs that we wanted to have with other
heroes and it's also super funny to see
him act with mario but also the rabbits
alright so we got a first look at a
couple of the planets what can you tell
us about beacon beach and pristine peaks
vegan beach is all about sun the beach
there's a great temple as well
but because of darkness and what cursa
the enemy of the game did
well everything became rainy depressing
when you arrive on the planet
so players have to uh remove uh on
beacon beach the darkness and let the
sun shine again and by doing so you
unlock tons of new quests so
pristin peaks on the other side is very
different vibe is very different it's
all about snow snowstorms
there's one big mountain to ascend uh
you'll go through different paths
caverns um and also reaching the palace
that is full of
mysteries puzzles but also a big fight
so yeah we decided to have for all the
planets um not just the first two ones
but we decided to have multiple zones
and regions per planet and um because
it's all about discovery um
and making sure that players have this
autonomy to check whatever he wants
or she wants and it's a big aspect of
the game
all right so who are the wardens that we
meet on these planets so the wardens are
those rabbit characters that the rulers
of their own planet but completely lost
on what to do next they are important
allies telling our heroes what to do
or
in order to bring back peace
and
we spent a lot of production efforts on
those wardens because they're they need
to be very funny and they are
they're weird quite unique they have
their own set of animations
tons of personality and we love them so
let's talk about gameplay now can you
tell us more about using spark powers
and techniques and the difference
between them they're very unique so you
can equip two of them per hero
so if you have three heroes in a battle
it means six which is a lot because they
each come with their own active and
passive bonuses fire spark could bring a
fire attack to your weapon but as well a
fire spike could also bring for a dash
so it's up to you to mix and match and
maybe you want to mix a fire one with a
water one because each of them also
protect you from the enemies and their
super effects based on that spark so
they're really really important in the
battle because you can equip any spark
with any hero so that's the big
difference as well with the techniques
because techniques are specific to the
heroes
so basically mixing the sparks and the
techniques together
plus the archetype of the hero
really creates tons of possibilities uh
for the players
yeah and speaking of players they're
this is for all players so newcomers
tactical game enthusiasts everyone in in
between how do you manage the balance of
making it for all players
it's a rabbids game it's a ubisoft game
but it's also a mario game so it's
really really key and important so
removing the grid and the cursor was a
way to avoid
the fear of testing the game if you
never played this type of games before
so
it was part of the decision why we
removed that but also because we wanted
to add more action and fluidity uh every
turn and everywhere and that was quite
important for mainstream players as well
yes we we have a community of players
now and they expect
more when it comes to tactics so when we
added the sparks we changed the skill
tree we added new archetypes for the
heroes or the enemies the new
ingredients like the items we have now
in the game so basically the strategy
and tactics are truly at the center of
the the gameplay it's a big push that
we've made
of course we have autofill options like
we had in the past and this will help
the players in case they don't want to
dig too deep
but yellowfield will never be as good as
doing it manually and this is something
that we want to teach those new players
as well well i'm so excited to play
thank you for speaking with me today and
telling us more about the game we are so
excited uh it's an incredible adventure
um very proud of what the team achieved
that's for sure
and uh we i guess we cannot wait to
reveal more but we'll watch out i'm not
spoiling too much let's prepare of
course all right well mario plus ravi's
sparks of hope is coming to nintendo
switch on october 20. thanks for
watching
[Music]
was hit hard
here live
server room identified perimeter bridge
over
where you go
[Music]
withdraw your men say again
i'm going in
[Music]
my turn
what's going on
what the
impossible i didn't think you spooked
this easy
micro recon drums
cute
you forgot this
[Music]
the data key on your jugular
you were saying
what was on that server
qcr shipment records question is
who wants eyes on it
and why
[Music]
[Music]
operation brutal swarm is coming to
rainbow six siege with a new attacker
who can launch enemy detecting bees plus
there's a new impact emp grenade
entering some loadouts and a host of
other new sorry what ah yes i did say
these micro air vehicles if you want to
get technical but yeah bees bees that
ping you all thanks to this guy
his name is grim and he hails from
singapore he's a three-speed attacker
who can wield the 5-5-2 commando assault
rifle or the sg cqb shotgun
he's got the p229 pistol as a secondary
and breach charges or claymores as
gadget options but the thing that's got
everybody talking is his kawan hive
launcher an intel gathering enemy
revealing unique ability fueled by bees
here's how it works the khawan hive
launcher shoots projectiles that stick
to surfaces when a projectile lands it
deploys a canister onto the floor the
canister opens up and bees
the bees form a swarm in a set area the
swarm does not move if you're caught in
the swarm or run into it the bees will
be all over you
you cannot swat them away your firearms
are useless against them you will be
tracked in real time while you are in
the swarm and pinged a few more times
even if you escape the swarm eventually
the bees will run out of juice and fall
away
if you live that long
obviously the swarm is a place that
defenders don't want to be so put it in
places you don't want them to go like
maybe that stairwell on your flank
you can also use the kawan hive launcher
to root defenders out of places you
think they might be like behind this
half wall on stadium or in this
particular corner of cafe
if you happen to tag an enemy maybe
they'll hunker down and hope you can't
get an angle on them and maybe your ally
will have a frag grenade handy
maybe the defender will catch a case of
ping panic and try to run away and maybe
lion's ee1d scan is active at that very
moment
grimm excels at clearing roamers
especially when teamed up with jackal
but he can also help attackers advance
on the objective in tandem with
operators like sends or gridlock or
anyone with smoke grenades
the range of his khawan hive launcher
gives grimm the power to exert influence
at a distance and even between floors
while remaining relatively safe himself
now defenders you don't want grimm's
ping happy pals to get up in your
business jaeger and wamai are your first
line of defense as their gadgets can
stop grimm's projectiles from landing
and releasing beats aruni's gates will
zap the projectiles as well though grimm
and his teammates might benefit from
using his launcher to clear her
obstructions
kaid and bandit are also decent
deterrents to grimm's efforts as
electricity will destroy his projectiles
but perhaps the most versatile grim
countering strategy is to bring mute a
canister that lands near a mute jammer
cannot deploy bees a player who is in a
mute jammer radius cannot be swarmed and
a swarmed player who enters the mute
jammer's area of effect will lose their
swarm immediately oh and then there's
vigil whose cloak ensures that bees
can't see him so if you're counting on
those bees to watch your flank while
he's in the match
beware grimm and his attacker allies
will have new territory for hunting down
enemies as operation brutal swarm
introduces the stadium map to the
full-time competitive roster initially
appearing in 2021's road to si event
stadium has been polished up for its
debut on the main stage
unbreakable glass walls create an
unusual degree of transparency between
attackers and defenders in certain
places and the gantry spawn high over
the main structure lets attackers
approach with style once inside make use
of the color-coded areas to sharpen your
call outs or just bring grim along for
some extra pinging power
operation brutal swarm is also dropping
some new gameplay changes including an
impact emp grenade that will grant more
attackers the ability to counter
electronic devices the radius is smaller
than thatcher's unique emp ability and
the impact detonation means you'll have
to act fast to time your breaches and
incursions and what have you
also some recoil changes to sustained
weapons fire are coming for pc players
only while
all players will benefit from increased
loadout customization you see weapon
attachments are being more widely
distributed across different weapon
types to give you more options to work
with be sure to spend some time in the
shooting range to get a feel for the
changes and take note that the damage
penalty from the suppressor has been
removed sneaky
a few more updates arriving with
operation brutal swarm include
improvements to the tactical map and a
change to the map ban system to help
increase map diversity
plus you'll now be able to report
cheaters using match replay to show the
receipts and the team will be rolling
out a new reputation penalty for abusive
text chat
finally two operator balancing updates
to look forward to later this season
players wearing rooks armor plates will
be able to use the withstand ability to
pick themselves up from dbno and
dekebby's logic bomb will affect dead
players who are using cameras in support
mode
operation brutal swarm is headed your
way and grimm is bringing a powerful new
tool for getting intel on defenders and
sowing panic among their ranks
he'll be available from day one with the
premium track of the brutal swarm battle
pass and unlockable two weeks later with
renown or r6 credits keep up with the
latest on siege by subscribing to this
channel and visit us at news.ubisoft.com
i've said what's active
[Music]
peggy eighteen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
team
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
rocksmith plus the new subscription
service that teaches you to play
electric acoustic and bass guitar
through your favorite songs is launching
on pc september 6th to learn more about
the music learning service we spoke with
music content director anthony martinez
so why did the team decide to make
rocksmith plus
so although we were very pleased with
the seven years of dlc support that we
had for rocksmith 2014
we knew that the foundation of the
software itself made it harder and
harder to support as the years went on
with rocksmith plus we wanted to build a
stronger more future-proof foundation to
build a live service on something that
would allow us to expand the song
library by the thousands and offer new
learning opportunities to players for
years to come
so how has the technology for rocksmith
plus evolved since rocksmith
so first off players can now play along
to rocksmith plus on pc
using our phone as mic technology within
the rocksmith plus connect app
that means that all players can
experience the benefits of rocksmith
state of the art note detection
technology and real-time feedback
without the use of any peripherals
in addition our new adaptive difficulty
system makes it easier for beginner and
intermediate players to get started
the new technology is able to adapt to
players skill levels by measuring the
total sum of their abilities rather than
catering to an individual's song
performance
what this means is that once you've
shown rocksmith plus that you know a
specific technique or chord you'll start
to see those elements more quickly
across all songs
adaptive difficulty does a really great
job of encouraging players to reach
beyond what they know to try new
techniques
and if it senses that the player might
be struggling a little bit with those
techniques it'll dial back the
difficulty offering a very personalized
approach to music learning
so how many songs will be available at
launch and how often will songs be added
well i'm very excited to share that
we're going to be launching rocksmith
plus with more than 5 000 songs which is
many times more than we ever released on
rocksmith 2014.
we plan to add more songs as well as
feature updates every month
the rocksmith plus library also offers
way more genres than we ever offered
before
including rock metal pop
regional folk music
we have a ton of music that's performed
in different languages around the world
it's very exciting so rocksmith plus has
many features and tools for learning but
which ones do you think are the most
important to highlight rocksmith plus
features a variety of video lessons and
practice tracks that acoustic and
electric bass and guitar players can use
to learn the skills that they need to
play any song in the rocksmith plus
library
on top of that if players are really
interested in
taking a deeper dive into some of the
content they can utilize riff repeater
players can access riff repeater by
simply pausing a song and from there
they have the ability to adjust
difficulty settings and even the speed
if they really want to slow things down
within riff repeater players can enable
a feature called note by note
effectively note by note asks players to
perform each note within a musical
passage correctly before the noteway
advances again and it's a great way for
beginner players to learn their first
riff or song and also a great way for
advanced players to learn more complex
solos
so what makes rocksmith plus unique as a
guitar learning service well for
starters we're the only product on the
market that has such a vast and diverse
library of licensed master recordings so
these aren't sound alikes or midi
versions but the legacy and contemporary
recordings that everyone knows that's a
very special experience to be able to
offer players who want to learn the
actual songs
on top of that our unique 3d noteway it
provides a very nice visual for various
techniques including bends which might
get lost in translation if you're trying
to read a tablature for example
what does the future of rocksmith plus
look like after launch
rocksmith plus is here to stay each
month we plan to release new songs
feature updates and more all of which is
included in the subscription and on top
of that we're looking forward to
releasing rocksmith plus on ios and
android later this year
so what are some of your favorite songs
to play on rocksmith plus
so my top three songs are should i stay
or should i go by the clash
rock and roll huchiku by rick derringer
and hollywood dreams by miguel
and i will say the first two are sort of
near and dear to my heart because um i
actually note track those years ago when
you spend a lot of time with songs and
you really
dive into those bass and guitar
arrangements and you know track them you
have a different musical relationship
with that
material
and i'll just never forget the
experience that i had while working on
those songs
miguel's hollywood dreams is a fantastic
song it's
it's interesting it's off of his album
wild heart
and to me that sort of represents the
cross section of r b and psychedelic
rock and
it introduces a very cool sounding
guitar riff and i feel like the song is
also a great representation of how we're
diversifying the catalog
do you have any tips for new players who
are just getting started
i would say have fun you know think
about those things that compelled you to
want to learn how to play guitar and
bass in the first place you know music
learning and
practicing guitar and bass is certainly
a passion of mine i've enjoyed it ever
since i was in the eighth grade
and so yeah i would just say have fun
and enjoy your time with rocksmith plus
rocksmith plus is available on pc
exclusively through the ubisoft store on
september 6th and will be available on
mobile later this year for more on
rocksmith plus head to news.ubsoft.com
rocksmith plus interactive music
learning available september 6th sign up
for updates at rocksmith.com
ohio
you want to get out of those wrecks and
into a real [ __ ] then build your
reputation
[Music]
welcome agent to the division resurgence
my name is james and today i want to
show you some exclusive gameplay
captured directly on mobile
in the division resurgence we have
recreated the original cover shooter
gameplay with a whole new story and
scope of missions
our journey today starts in a location
that should feel familiar it's your base
of operations
let's join up with our teammate and
start our mission
as we walk out of the base of operations
we get our first glimpse at a new york
recreated in your mobile device
the game is totally open world and the
city is huge
so we'll be using the minimap tool to
identify the task at hand and pinpoint
its location our route is now
highlighted and we are free to roam
around explore or head straight to our
destination
after a short walk around the block we
engage with the selected side activity
and encounter our first enemies
the division resurgence brings new
classes to the game and for this mission
my teammate is using the vanguard
specialization allowing him to spot our
targets
as a demolitionist i'm an explosive
expert and have access to the fan
favorite seeker mines for a quick and
easy takeout
as you can see specializations or
classes enhance the strategic layer to
the game each with its own abilities and
choice of skill trees
the interface has been completely
adapted to mobile placing all the
controls at your fingertips and
customizable to your preferences this
allows you to quickly engage your
targets use skills and take cover to be
as effective as possible during combat
throughout your exploration of the open
world you will encounter many different
factions each with its unique enemy
archetypes and combat styles some even
using drones which can be really hard to
get
anyway
looting and crafting are key to making
sure you've always got the best weapons
and gear
detecting
hostile contacts
the time needed for missions activities
and encounters has been reduced enabling
you to game on the go in short bursts
with the division resurgence we want to
ensure players can equip a vast array of
weapons and gear and tailor their
character to their preferred play style
or have fun theorycrafting the best
builds for dealing with various enemies
situations or missions
here we are going through our latest
finds and making sure we are truly
invincible
it's time now to head back out to see
what the city that never sleeps has in
store for us thank you for joining us
today do make sure to register now for a
chance to play in the closed alpha we
hope to see you all very soon in the
division resurgence
the division resurgence is taking you
back to new york city to see where it
all began it's a free to play third
person shooter and it's coming to ios
and android we've got the details on a
new enemy faction new specializations
the new storyline and it's all here in
our interview with executive producer
fabrice navrez
this is a new story in the division
canon and it takes place
you are the first wave arriving in new
york city is that correct the overall
objective was to make sure that we give
a
unique story for division fans to enjoy
to give more details about the division
universe but also for newcomers people
that are not familiar with the division
one and the division two to have a good
start and so you will start with the
first wave before the division one event
and then a big chunk of the game is
actually after the division one
and before the division two and from
there we will expand the stories
now that first wave gave rise to rogue
agents rogue agents of course some of
the not just toughest enemies but also
most uh sort of developed characters in
the division franchise are we gonna be
meeting some new characters some new
faces uh that are really part of of how
this whole thing unfolded we are doing
two things actually it's first to uh to
meet with people that are known from the
division one or the or the division two
uh which is interesting to meet them
before what happened actually in the in
the division one especially and we're
also introducing new villains will we be
seeing familiar factions new factions
who are we going to be fighting out
there in the streets as a player you
will meet with the factions from uh from
the previous helpers but we also created
dedicated factions uh one of them is the
freeman for example so it starts with
okay what what a bunch of engineers
civil walkers people that are know how
to build stuff will behave in a collapse
in new york city
well they will do their own arsenal they
will be their own weapons and will also
introduce a brand new gameplay to have
new challenges for the player that plays
very differently from from the former
fractions specializations big part of
the division ii not just in terms of
special weapons that can change the tide
of battle but also a whole complement of
abilities mods and buffs are there new
specializations coming for the division
resurgence
absolutely you will find a
specialization you used to have in the
division too but also i did a new ones
if you want it to to allow the player to
change specialization when he wants to
make sure that when you're playing in
cooperation with your friends for
example that actually you can you can
kind of adapt your playstyle to find the
right synergy in your team so so the key
here is really flexibility and bringing
new new cool stuff uh in your arsenal if
you want to play five minutes ten
minutes you can if you want to go into a
more intense focus game station of 2-3
hours it's possible as well you can
basically play the game a bit uh
fitting it with your your time
the second thing we're looking at also
it's to uh to give a lot of options for
the player to customize the the controls
for example to make sure they are very
comfortable with that uh with with the
play style uh so so that's that's really
the the key there and it's also how we
take advantage of putting the division
on the mobile phone
it's a faithful division game so we had
a lot of great inspiration to take from
of course it's adapted for a small
screen
to be easy to read but you will you will
feel at home basically with your overall
ui style playing with friends playing
solo these are both different ways
you've been able to play the division in
the past how has that kind of translated
to the mobile platform being able to
jump into solo being able to jump into
co-op
how have you sort of tuned that for
mobile experience
uh i would say it's it's quite similar
to what you would expect from the
division so it's basically you can
either plan to play with your friends
from there you can do all type of
activity in the open world go to play
the campaigns etc uh the game is is a
memo at art also so if you want if you
meet some strangers that looks helpful
well you can play with them and and and
and explore the city uh and where we're
pushing a bit more the boundaries is on
the plan system where basically what we
want to have it's to have
a group of players that are gathering
together and try to improve the
situation in new york city and basically
all the tasks that is being made by
by the the clan members is basically
improving the overall situation so it's
you're not alone we talked about
specializations but of course that's
only one part of your arsenal as a
division agent the gear you're wearing
the weapons you're wielding the mods you
have on them and the way you acquire
them either by looting them uh from your
enemies from a from a cache or by
crafting them
talking about how that kind of depth of
customization has translated to the
division resurgence uh so that's
something we wanted to keep the
complexity the terrorist crafting the
min maxing
the division resurgences rpg and that
means that actually players will be able
to really look on how to optimize
everything to get the best build in a
specific situation so we kept
most of the system you would expect from
the division of course it's adapted you
start with a specialization that he's
kind of increasing the number of options
it means also different synergy with the
guns but uh but you will have a quite
quite complete mix actually to uh
to find the best play style excellent
can get really into it there now folks
before we go the division resurgence
wants you to play the game early in
upcoming tests so go to
thedivisionresurgence.com to sign up for
a chance to get into the closed alpha
this july fabrice can you give us an
idea of what the team is hoping to learn
from these tests
if you have the chance to play it it's
very important that we get your
feedbacks and the the key there for us
is to really understand how you play the
game uh how do you like what we've done
with the control with your whole pacing
the whole level design and how we uh we
uh we put uh
new york city so it's really focused on
the gameplay experience and the
immersion of the open world sounds good
fabrice thanks for taking the time to
tell us more about the division
resurgence sign up for a chance to join
upcoming tests at
thedivisionresurgence.com
subscribe to this channel and keep up
with the latest ubisoft news at
news.ubisoft.com
it's a goddamn grenade
cargo secured jtf notified for pickup
our guys have arrived
there is a place
you know
the place
it's on your fridge
on your phone in your head
it's everywhere
everything you're missing
everything you've been working for
escape mystery danger adventure
life as it was meant to be
so forget about your job
about your career about reputation about
money all the shitty things that drag
you down every single day
and reconnect with mother nature
let her blow your mind
and just
let go
come have a taste
because this place
it's not a postcard
it's not a phone background
it's real
and it's waiting for you
[Music]
join us
come to paradise
[Music]
are you ready for this
of course you are
come on don't be shy don't let a fancy
suit impress you
don't let a thousand fancy suits impress
you
be the thorn in history's side
choose the greatest enemies
the captain
sorry mate
the emperor
the boss's boss
and make even greater friends
decent work leonardo
don't just pick a fight
start a revolution
get the bigger picture
go too far
go too fast
face the invisible
[Music]
the impossible
the unspeakable
welcome to the greatest playground
history
[Music]
so
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope takes
place in a whimsical galaxy the result
of the merge of mario and rabbids
universes
[Music]
but this galaxy is in danger
as cursa a dark entity wants to absorb
all its energy
its influence has spread all over the
world
and is made visible by darkness
cursa has also sent its minions to
capture the sparks
born from the merge of lumas and rabbids
[Music]
sparks are almost defenseless against
cursa
but mario and his friends will come to
their rescue and save the galaxy from
this terrible threat
[Music]
wow
[Music]
delve into many worlds and environments
in your quest to defeat cursa
and have the freedom to explore those
worlds as you wish
[Music]
throughout their journey mario and his
friends will meet a cast of
unforgettable characters
some of them will give you missions to
complete
[Music]
those quests are the opportunity to
explore worlds lush and brimming with
content full of challenges to overcome
and mysteries to uncover
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
new allies will join mario and his
friends in their quest
some are eager to join the fight
some not so much
[Music]
even bowser joins the team in an effort
to reclaim his lost army
[Music]
but curses unexpected minions will stand
in their way to protect the galaxy and
save the sparks heroes will have to be
brave and they will have to fight
[Music]
make your way through a whole host of
battles
lead a team of three heroes you select
control directly and move in real time
in tactical dynamic battles
[Music]
use a variety of tools to navigate the
battlefield
flank your foes
and find opportunities to thwart them
[Music]
adapt and use all the tools at your
disposal including your enemies
[Music]
each hero is equipped with a specific
weapon
from handy double shots
to flashy explosive projectiles to
dazzling melee attacks
they all offer complimentary play styles
once the heroes finish their turn it's
time for the enemies to step up
make sure to take cover to avoid attacks
because your foes won't miss an
opportunity to take aim at your heroes
each of our heroes has a unique
technique
shield your allies in battle
prepare a devastating counter-attack
or put your enemies to sleep
techniques will always prove useful if
used in the right context
each battle one will grant experience
points to the team and the heroes will
level up allowing them to grow more
powerful
in an intense battle
mario and his friends can count on the
help of the sparks
each hero can harness their powers in
battle
sparks open a whole world of tactical
possibilities
clever use of their abilities can truly
make the difference between defeat
and victory
[Music]
teamwork is key to gaining the upper
hand
use all the tools at your disposal to
set up devastating combos and win
difficult battles
this was just a glimpse of the journey
that awaits mario and his friends
where the end of a quest is always the
beginning of a new adventure
meet enchanting and enduring characters
face powerful enemies during epic
encounters
[Music]
find the sparks and save them from cursa
[Music]
embark on this great adventure
for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope is
coming to switch this fall bringing back
beloved heroes and teaming them up with
new allies including a very unexpected
one
[Music]
to learn more about bowser joining our
heroes a couple of the planets your team
will explore and using new powers and
techniques in battle we spoke to lead
producer xavier manzanares
what were some of the first thoughts
when you started thinking about new
characters to bring to sparks of hope
you don't want to um to add random
characters to the cast but think in a
way that how would they impact the
battles
edge
the the new rabbit hero for instance
is all about close quarter combat and
reacting to the enemies mid and close
range
and she has tons of personality too so
we're excited also because we saw bowser
is joining our heroes how did the idea
to make bowser and ally come about so we
wanted to add a nintendo character that
would be um surprising for the players
so having mario and bowser in the same
team is quite unique we truly love the
idea of having bowser as well in a
tactical game bowser fits perfectly the
combo
needs that we wanted to have with other
heroes and it's also super funny to see
him act with mario but also the rabbits
alright so we gotta first look at a
couple of the planets what can you tell
us about beacon beach and pristine peaks
vegan beach is all about sun the beach
there's a great temple as well but
because of darkness and what cursa
the big enemy of the game did
well everything became rainy depressing
when you arrive on the planet
so players have to remove
on beacon beach the darkness
and let the sun shine again and by doing
so you unlock tons of new quests so
pristin peaks on the other side is very
different vibe is very different it's
all about snow snowstorms
there's one big mountain to ascend uh
you'll go through different paths
caverns um and also reaching the palace
that is full of
mysteries puzzles but also a big fight
so yeah we decided to have for all the
planets um not just the first two ones
but we decided to have multiple zones
and regions per planet and
um because it's all about discovery um
and making sure that players have this
autonomy to check whatever he wants
or she wants and it's a big aspect of
the game
all right so who are the wardens that we
meet on these planets so the wardens are
those rabid characters the rulers of
their own planet but completely lost on
what to do next
they are important allies uh telling our
heroes what to do or
in order to bring back peace
and
we spent a lot of production efforts on
those wardens because they're they need
to be very funny and they are um they're
weird quite unique they have their own
set of animations
tons of personality and uh we love them
so let's talk about gameplay now can you
tell us more about using spark powers
and techniques and the difference
between them they're very unique so you
can equip two of them per hero
so if you have three heroes in a battle
it means uh six
which is a lot because they each come
with their own active and passive
bonuses fire spark could bring a fire
attack to your weapon but as well a fire
spike could also bring uh for a dash so
it's up to you to mix and match and
maybe you want to mix the fire one with
a water one because each of them also
protect you from the enemies and their
super effects based on that spark so
they're really really important in the
battle because you can equip any spark
with any hero so that's the big
difference as well with the techniques
because techniques are specific to the
heroes
so basically mixing the sparks and the
techniques together
plus the archetype of the hero
really creates tons of possibilities
for the players
yeah and speaking of players there this
is for all players so newcomers tactical
game enthusiasts everyone in between how
do you manage the balance of making it
for all players
it's a rabbids game it's a ubisoft game
but it's also a mario game so it's
really really key and important so
removing the grid and the cursor was a
way to avoid
the fear of testing the game if you
never played this type of games before
so
it was part of the decision why we
removed that but also because we wanted
to add more action and fluidity uh every
turn and everywhere and that was quite
important for mainstream players as well
yes we we have a community of players
now and they expect
more when it comes to tactics so when we
added the sparks we changed the skill
tree we added new archetypes for the
heroes or the enemies the new
ingredients like the items we have now
in the game so basically the strategy
and tactics are truly at the center of
the the gameplay it's a big push that
we've made
of course we have autofill options like
we had in the past and this will help
the players in case they don't want to
dig too deep
but the autofill will never be as good
as doing it manually and this is
something that we want to teach those
new players as well well i'm so excited
to play thank you for speaking with me
today and telling us more about the game
we are so excited
it's an incredible adventure
very proud of what the team achieved
that's for sure
and uh we i guess we cannot wait to
reveal more but we'll watch out i'm not
spoiling too much let's be here of
course all right well mario plus ravi's
sparks of hope is coming to nintendo
switch on october 20. thanks for
watching
[Music]
was hit hard
here live
server room identify perimeter bridge
over
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm going in
[Music]
my turn
what's going on
what the
impossible
didn't think you spooked this easy
micro recon drums
cute
you forgot this
[Music]
the data key
on your jugular
you were saying
what was on that server
shipment records question is
who wants eyes on it
and why
[Music]
[Music]
operation brutal swarm is coming to
rainbow six siege with a new attacker
who can launch enemy detecting bees plus
there's a new impact emp grenade
entering some loadouts and a host of
other new
sorry what ah yes i did say bees micro
air vehicles if you want to get
technical but yeah bees
bees that ping you all thanks to this
guy
his name is grim and he hails from
singapore he's a three-speed attacker
who can wield the 5-5-2 commando assault
rifle or the sg cqb shotgun
he's got the p229 pistol as a secondary
and breach charges or claymores as
gadget options but the thing that's got
everybody talking is his kawan hive
launcher an intel gathering enemy
revealing unique ability fueled by bees
here's how it works the kawan hive
launcher shoots projectiles that stick
to surfaces when a projectile lands it
deploys a canister onto the floor the
canister opens up and bees
the bees form a swarm in a set area the
swarm does not move if you're caught in
the swarm or run into it the bees will
be all over you
you cannot swat them away your firearms
are useless against them you will be
tracked in real time while you are in
the swarm and pinged a few more times
even if you escape the swarm eventually
the bees will run out of juice and fall
away
if you live that long
obviously the swarm is a place that
defenders don't want to be so put it in
places you don't want them to go like
maybe that stairwell on your flank
you can also use the kawan hive launcher
to root defenders out of places you
think they might be like behind this
half wall on stadium or in this
particular corner of cafe
if you happen to tag an enemy maybe
they'll hunker down and hope you can't
get an angle on them and maybe your ally
will have a frag grenade handy
maybe the defender will catch a case of
ping panic and try to run away and maybe
lion's ee1d scan is active at that very
moment
grimm excels at clearing roamers
especially when teamed up with jackal
but he can also help attackers advance
on the objective in tandem with
operators like sends or gridlock or
anyone with smoke grenades
the range of his khawan hive launcher
gives grim the power to exert influence
at a distance and even between floors
while remaining relatively safe himself
now defenders you don't want grimm's
ping happy pals to get up in your
business
jaeger and wamai are your first line of
defense as their gadgets can stop
grimm's projectiles from landing and
releasing beats aruni's gates will zap
the projectiles as well though grimm and
his teammates might benefit from using
his launcher to clear her obstructions
kaid and bandit are also decent
deterrents to grimm's efforts as
electricity will destroy his projectiles
but perhaps the most versatile grim
countering strategy is to bring mute
a canister that lands near a mute jammer
cannot deploy bees a player who is in a
mute jammer radius cannot be swarmed and
a swarmed player who enters the mute
jammer's area of effect will lose their
swarm immediately oh and then there's
vigil whose cloak ensures that bees
can't see him so if you're counting on
those bees to watch your flank while
he's in the match
beware
grimm and his attacker allies will have
new territory for hunting down enemies
as operation brutal swarm introduces the
stadium map to the full-time competitive
roster initially appearing in 2021's
road to si event stadium has been
polished up for its debut on the main
stage
unbreakable glass walls create an
unusual degree of transparency between
attackers and defenders in certain
places and the gantry spawn high over
the main structure lets attackers
approach with style
once inside make use of the color-coded
areas to sharpen your callouts or just
bring grim along for some extra pinging
power
operation brutal swarm is also dropping
some new gameplay changes including an
impact emp grenade that will grant more
attackers the ability to counter
electronic devices the radius is smaller
than thatcher's unique emp ability and
the impact's detonation means you'll
have to act fast to time your breaches
and incursions and what have you
also some recoil changes to sustained
weapons fire are coming for pc players
only while all players will benefit from
increased loadout customization you see
weapon attachments are being more widely
distributed across different weapon
types to give you more options to work
with be sure to spend some time in the
shooting range to get a feel for the
changes and take note that the damage
penalty from the suppressor has been
removed sneaky
a few more updates arriving with
operation brutal swarm include
improvements to the tactical map and a
change to the map ban system to help
increase map diversity
plus you'll now be able to report
cheaters using match replay to show the
receipts and the team will be rolling
out a new reputation penalty for abusive
text chat
finally two operator balancing updates
to look forward to later this season
players wearing rooks armor plates will
be able to use the withstand ability to
pick themselves up from dbno and
dekebby's logic bomb will affect dead
players who are using cameras in support
mode
operation brutal swarm is headed your
way and grimm is bringing a powerful new
tool for getting intel on defenders and
sowing panic among their ranks
he'll be available from day one with the
premium track of the brutal swarm battle
pass and unlockable two weeks later with
renown or r6 credits keep up with the
latest on siege by subscribing to this
channel and visit us at news.ubisoft.com
i've said what's
op4
active
[Music]
peggy 18.
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
rocksmith plus the new subscription
service that teaches you to play
electric acoustic and bass guitar
through your favorite songs is launching
on pc september 6th to learn more about
the music learning service we spoke with
music content director anthony martinez
so why did the team decide to make
rocksmith plus
so although we were very pleased with
the seven years of dlc support that we
had for rocksmith 2014
we knew that the foundation of the
software itself made it harder and
harder to support as the years went on
with rocksmith plus we wanted to build a
stronger more future proof foundation to
build a live service on something that
would allow us to expand the song
library by the thousands and offer new
learning opportunities to players for
years to come
so how has the technology for rocksmith
plus evolved since rocksmith
so first off players can now play along
to rocksmith plus on pc
using our phone as mic technology within
the rocksmith plus connect app
that means that all players can
experience the benefits of rocksmith
state of the art note detection
technology and real-time feedback
without the use of any peripherals
in addition our new adaptive difficulty
system makes it easier for beginner and
intermediate players to get started
the new technology
is able to adapt a player's skill levels
by measuring the total sum of their
abilities rather than catering to an
individual's song performance
what this means is that once you've
shown rocksmith plus that you know a
specific technique or chord you'll start
to see those elements more quickly
across all songs
adaptive difficulty does a really great
job of encouraging players to reach
beyond what they know to try new
techniques and if it senses that the
player might be struggling a little bit
with those techniques it'll dial back
the difficulty offering a very
personalized approach to music learning
so how many songs will be available at
launch and how often will songs be added
well i'm very excited to share that
we're going to be launching rocksmith
plus with more than 5000 songs which is
many times more than we ever released on
rocksmith 2014.
we plan to add more songs as well as
feature updates every month
the rocksmith plus library also offers
way more genres than we ever offered
before
including rock metal pop
regional folk music
we have a ton of music that's performed
in different languages around the world
it's very exciting so rocksmith plus has
many features and tools for learning but
which ones do you think are the most
important to highlight rocksmith plus
features a variety of video lessons
and practice tracks that acoustic and
electric bass and guitar players can use
to learn the skills that they need to
play any song in the rocksmith plus
library
on top of that if players are really
interested in taking a deeper dive into
some of the content they can utilize
riff repeater
players can access riff repeater by
simply pausing a song and from there
they have the ability to adjust
difficulty settings and even the speed
if they really want to slow things down
within riff repeater players can enable
a feature called note by note
effectively note by note asks players to
perform each note within a musical
passage correctly before the noteway
advances again and it's a great way for
beginner players to learn their first
riff or song and also a great way for
advanced players to learn more complex
solos
so what makes rocksmith plus unique as a
guitar learning service well for
starters we're the only product on the
market that has such a vast and diverse
library of licensed master recordings so
these aren't sound alikes or midi
versions but
the legacy and contemporary recordings
that everyone knows that's a very
special experience to be able to offer
players who want to learn the actual
songs
on top of that our unique 3d noteway it
provides a very nice visual
for various techniques including bends
which might get lost in translation if
you're trying to read a tablature for
example
what does the future of rocksmith plus
look like after launch
rocksmith plus is here to stay each
month we plan to release new songs
feature updates and more all of which is
included in the subscription and on top
of that we're looking forward to
releasing rocksmith plus on ios and
android later this year
so what are some of your favorite songs
to play on rocksmith plus
so my top three songs are should i stay
or should i go by the clash
rock and roll hoochie coo by rick
derringer
and hollywood dreams by miguel
and i will say the first two are sort of
near and dear to my heart because um i
actually note track those years ago when
you spend a lot of time with songs and
you really uh dive into those
bass and guitar arrangements and you
note track them you have a different
musical relationship with that
material
and i'll just never forget the
experience that i had while working on
those songs
miguel's hollywood dreams is a fantastic
song it's
it's interesting it's off of his album
wild heart
and to me that sort of represents the
cross section of r b and psychedelic
rock and
it introduces a very cool sounding
guitar riff and i feel like the song is
also a great representation of how we're
diversifying the catalog
do you have any tips for new players who
are just getting started
i would say have fun
you know think about those things that
compelled you to want to learn how to
play guitar and bass in the first place
you know music learning and practicing
guitar and bass is certainly a passion
of mine i've enjoyed it ever since i was
in the eighth grade and so yeah i would
just say have fun and enjoy your time
with rocksmith plus
rocksmith plus is available on pc
exclusively through the ubisoft store on
september 6th and will be available on
mobile later this year for more on
rocksmith plus head to news.ubisoft.com
rocksmith plus interactive music
learning available september 6th sign up
for updates at rocksmith.com
ohio
you want to get out of those wrecks
welcome agent to the division resurgence
my name is james and today i want to
show you some exclusive gameplay
captured directly on mobile
in the division resurgence we have
recreated the original cover shooter
gameplay with a whole new story and
scope of missions
our journey today starts in a location
that should feel familiar it's your base
of operations
let's join up with our teammate and
start our mission
as we walk out of the base of operations
we get our first glimpse at a new york
recreated in your mobile device
the game is totally open world and the
city is huge
so we'll be using the minimap tool to
identify the task at hand and pinpoint
its location
our route is now highlighted and we are
free to roam around explore or head
straight to our destination
after a short walk around the block we
engage with the selected side activity
and encounter our first enemies
the division resurgence brings new
classes to the game and for this mission
my teammate is using the vanguard
specialization allowing him to spot our
targets
as a demolitionist i'm an explosive
expert and have access to the fan parent
seeker mines for a quick and easy
takeout
as you can see specializations or
classes enhance the strategic layer to
the game each with its own abilities and
choice of skill trees
the interface has been completely
adapted to mobile placing all the
controls at your fingertips and
customizable to your preferences
this allows you to quickly engage your
targets use skills and take cover to be
as effective as possible during combat
throughout your exploration of the open
world you will encounter many different
factions each with its unique enemy
archetypes and combat styles some even
using drones which can be really hard to
get
anyway
looting and crafting are key to making
sure you've always got the best weapons
and
detecting gear hostile contacts
the time needed for missions activities
and encounters has been reduced enabling
you to game on the go in short bursts
with the division resurgence we want to
ensure players can equip a vast array of
weapons and gear and tailor their
character to their preferred play style
or have fun theorycrafting the best
builds for dealing with various enemies
situations or missions
here we are going through our latest
finds and making sure we are truly
invincible
it's time now to head back out to see
what the city that never sleeps has in
store for us
thank you for joining us today do make
sure to register now for a chance to
play in the closed alpha we hope to see
you all very soon in the division
resurgence
the division resurgence is taking you
back to new york city to see where it
all began it's a free-to-play
third-person shooter and it's coming to
ios and android we've got the details on
a new enemy faction new specializations
the new storyline and it's all here in
our interview with executive producer
fabrice navrez
this is a new story in the division
canon and it takes place
you are the first wave arriving in new
york city is that correct the overall
objective was to make sure that we give
a
unique story for division fans to enjoy
to give more details about the division
universe but also for newcomers people
that are not familiar with the division
one and the division two to have a good
start and so you will start with the
first wave before the division one event
and then a big chunk of the game is
actually after the division one
and before the division two and from
there we will expand the stories
now that first wave gave rise to rogue
agents rogue agents of course some of
the not just toughest enemies but also
most uh sort of developed characters in
the division franchise are we gonna be
meeting some new characters some new
faces uh that are really part of of how
this whole thing unfolded we are doing
two things actually it's first to uh to
meet with people that are known from the
division one or the or the division two
uh which is interesting to meet them
before what happened actually in the in
the division one especially and we're
also introducing new vlans will we be
seeing familiar factions new factions
who are we going to be fighting out
there in the streets as a player you
will meet with the factions from uh from
the previous purpose but we also created
dedicated factions uh one of them is the
freeman for example so
it starts with okay what what a bunch of
engineers civil walkers people that are
know how to build stuff will behave in a
collapse in new york city
well they will do their own arsenal they
will be their own weapons and will also
introduce a brand new gameplay to have
new challenges for the player that plays
very differently from from the former
factions specializations big part of the
division two not just in terms of
special weapons that can change the tide
of battle but also a whole complement of
abilities mods and buffs are there new
specializations coming for the division
resurgence
absolutely you will find a
specialization you used to have in the
division too but also i did a new ones
if we wanted to to allow the player to
change specialization
when he wants to make sure that when
you're playing in cooperation with your
friends for example that actually you
can you can kind of adapt your playstyle
to find the right synergy in your team
so so the key here is really flexibility
and bringing new new cool stuff uh in
your arsenal if you want to play five
minutes ten minutes you can if you want
to go into a more intense focus game
station of two three hours it's possible
as well you can basically play the game
a bit uh
fitting it with your your time uh the
second thing we're looking at also it's
to uh to give you a lot of options for
the player to customize the the controls
for example to make sure they are very
comfortable with that uh with with the
playstyle uh so so that's that's really
the the key there and it's also how we
take advantage of uh of putting the
division on the mobile phone
it's a faithful division game so we had
a lot of great inspiration to take from
of course it's adapted for a small
screen
to be easy to read but you will you will
feel at home basically with your overall
ui style playing with friends playing
solo these are both different ways
you've been able to play the division in
the past how has that kind of translated
to the mobile platform being able to
jump into solo being able to jump into
co-op um how have you sort of tuned that
for mobile experience
i would say it's it's quite similar to
what you would expect from the division
so it's basically you can either plan to
play with your friends from there you
can do all type of activity in the open
world go to play the campaigns etc uh
the game is is a memo at art also so if
you want if you meet some strangers that
looks helpful well you can play with
them and and and and explore the city uh
and where we're pushing a bit more the
banderas is on the planned system where
basically what we want to have it's to
have
a group of players that are gathering
together and try to improve the
situation in new york city and basically
all the tasks that is being made by
by the clan members is basically
improving the overall situation so it's
you're not alone we talked about
specializations but of course that's
only one part of your arsenal as a
division agent the gear you're wearing
the weapons you're wielding the mods you
have on them and the way you acquire
them either by looting them uh from your
enemies from uh from a cache or by
crafting them
talking about how that kind of depth of
customization has translated to the
division resurgence uh so that's
something we wanted to keep the
complexity the terrorist crafting the
min maxing uh the division resurgences
rpg and that means that actually players
will be able to really look on how to
optimize everything to get the best
build in a specific situation so we kept
most of the system you would expect from
the division of course it's adapted you
start with the specialization that is
kind of increasing the number of options
it means also different synergy with the
guns but but you will have a quite
quite complete mix actually to uh to
find the best play style excellent can
get really into it there now folks
before we go the division resurgence
wants you to play the game early in
upcoming tests so go to
thedivisionresurgence.com to sign up for
a chance to get into the closed alpha
this july fabrice can you give us an
idea of what the team is hoping to learn
from these tests
if you have the chance to play it it's
very important that we get your
feedbacks and the the key there for us
is to really understand how you play the
game
how do you like what we've done with the
control with your vault pacing the
overall level design and how we uh we
put
new york city so it's really focused on
the gameplay experience and the
immersion of the the open world sounds
good fabrice thanks for taking the time
to tell us more about the division
resurgence sign up for a chance to join
upcoming tests at
thedivisionresurgence.com
subscribe to this channel and keep up
with the latest ubisoft news at
news.ubisoft.com
it's a goddamn grenade
cargo secured jtf notified for pickup
our guys have arrived
there is a place
you know
the place
it's on your fridge
on your phone in your head
it's everywhere everything you're
missing
everything you've been working for
escape mystery danger adventure
life as it was meant to be
so forget about your job about your
career about reputation about money all
the shitty things that drag you down
every single day
and reconnect with mother nature
let her blow your mind
and just
let go
come have a taste
because this place
it's not a postcard
it's not a phone background
it's real
and it's waiting for you
[Music]
join us
come to paradise
[Music]
are you ready for this
of course you are
come on don't be shy
don't let a fancy suit impress you
don't let a thousand fancy suits impress
you
be the thorn in history's side
choose the greatest enemies
the captain
sorry mate
the emperor
the boss's boss
[Music]
and make even greater friends
decent work leonardo
don't just pick a fight
start a revolution
get the bigger picture
go too far
go too fast
face the invisible
[Music]
the impossible
the unspeakable
welcome to the greatest playground
history
hmm
[Music]
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope takes
place in a whimsical galaxy the result
of the merge of mario and rabbids
universes
[Music]
but this galaxy is in danger
as cursa a dark entity wants to absorb
all its energy
its influence has spread all over the
world
and is made visible by darkness
cursa has also sent its minions to
capture the sparks
born from the merge of lumas and rabbids
[Music]
sparks are almost defenseless against
cursa
but mario and his friends will come to
their rescue and save the galaxy from
this terrible threat
[Music]
wow
[Music]
delve into many worlds and environments
in your quest to defeat cursa
[Music]
and have the freedom to explore those
worlds as you wish
[Music]
throughout their journey mario and his
friends will meet a cast of
unforgettable characters
some of them will give you missions to
complete
[Music]
those quests are the opportunity to
explore worlds lush and brimming with
content full of challenges to overcome
and mysteries to uncover
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
new allies will join mario and his
friends in their quest
some are eager to join the fight
some
not so much
[Music]
even bowser joins the team in an effort
to reclaim his lost army
[Music]
but curses unexpected minions will stand
in their way to protect the galaxy and
save the sparks heroes will have to be
brave and they will have to fight
[Music]
make your way through a whole host of
battles
lead a team of three heroes you select
control directly and move in real time
in tactical dynamic battles
[Music]
use a variety of tools to navigate the
battlefield
flank your foes
and find opportunities to thwart them
[Music]
adapt and use all the tools at your
disposal
including your enemies
each hero is equipped with a specific
weapon
from handy double shots
to flashy explosive projectiles to
dazzling melee attacks
they all offer complimentary play styles
once the heroes finish their turn it's
time for the enemies to step up
make sure to take cover to avoid attacks
because your foes won't miss an
opportunity to take aim at your heroes
each of our heroes has a unique
technique
shield your allies in battle
prepare a devastating counter-attack
or put your enemies to sleep
techniques will always prove useful if
used in the right context
each battle one will grant experience
points to the team and the heroes will
level up allowing them to grow more
powerful
in an intense battle mario and his
friends can count on the help of the
sparks
each hero can harness their powers in
battle
sparks open a whole world of tactical
possibilities
clever use of their abilities can truly
make the difference between defeat and
victory
[Music]
teamwork is key to gaining the upper
hand
use all the tools at your disposal to
set up devastating combos and win
difficult battles
this was just a glimpse of the journey
that awaits mario and his friends
where the end of a quest is always the
beginning of a new adventure
meet enchanting and enduring characters
face powerful enemies during epic
encounters
[Music]
find the sparks and save them from cursa
embark on this great adventure
for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
so
[Music]
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope is
coming to switch this fall bringing back
beloved heroes and teaming them up with
new allies including a very unexpected
one
to learn more about bowser joining our
heroes a couple of the planets your team
will explore and using new powers and
techniques in battle we spoke to lead
producer xavier manzanares
what were some of the first thoughts
when you started thinking about new
characters to bring to sparks of hope
you don't want to um to add random
characters to the cast but think in a
way that how would they impact the
battles
edge
the the new rabbit hero for instance
is all about close quarter combat and
reacting to the enemy's mid and close
range
and she has tons of personality too so
we're excited also because we saw bowser
is joining our heroes how did the idea
to make bowser and ally come about so we
wanted to add a nintendo character that
would be
surprising for the players so having
mario and bowser in the same team
is quite unique we truly love the idea
of having bowser as well in a tactical
game bowser fits perfectly the combo
needs that we wanted to have with other
heroes and it's also super funny to see
him act with mario but also the rabbits
alright so we got a first look at a
couple of the planets what can you tell
us about beacon beach and pristine peaks
beacon beach is all about sun the beach
there's a great temple as well
but because of darkness and what cursa
the big enemy of the game did
while everything became rainy depressing
when you arrive on the planet
so players have to remove
on beacon beach the darkness and let the
sun shine again and by doing so you
unlock tons of new quests so
pristin peaks on the other side is very
different vibe is very different it's
all about snow snowstorms
there's one big mountain to ascend
you'll go through different paths
caverns um and also reaching the palace
that is full of um mysteries puzzles but
also a big fight
so yeah we decided to have for all the
planets um not just the first two ones
but we decided to have multiple zones
and regions per planet and
um because it's all about discovery um
and making sure that players have this
autonomy to check whatever he wants or
she wants and is a big aspect of the
game
all right so who are the wardens that we
meet on these planets so the wardens are
those rabid characters that they're
rulers of their own planet but
completely lost on what to do next they
are important allies uh telling our
heroes what to do or um in order to
bring back peace
and um we spent a lot of production
efforts on those wardens because they're
they need to be very funny and they are
um they're weird quite unique they have
their own set of animations
tons of personality and we love them so
let's talk about gameplay now can you
tell us more about using spark powers
and techniques and the difference
between them they're very unique so you
can equip two of them per hero
so if you have three heroes in a battle
it means uh six
which is a lot because they each come
with their own active and passive
bonuses fire spark could bring a fire
attack to your weapon but as well a fire
spike could also bring for a dash so
it's up to you to mix and match and
maybe you want to mix a fire one with a
water one because each of them also
protect you from the enemies and their
super effects based on that spark so
they're really really important in the
battle because you can equip any spark
with any hero so that's the big
difference as well with the techniques
because techniques are specific to the
heroes
so basically mixing the sparks and the
techniques together
plus the archetype of the hero
really creates tons of possibilities
for the players
yeah and speaking of players they're
this is for all players so newcomers
tactical game enthusiasts everyone in in
between how do you manage the balance of
making it for all players
it's a rabbids game it's a ubisoft game
but it's also a mario game so it's
really really key and important so
removing the grid and the cursor was a
way to avoid
the fear of testing the game if you
never played this type of games before
so
it was part of the decision why we
removed that but also because we wanted
to add more action and fluidity uh every
turn and everywhere and that was quite
important for mainstream players as well
yes we we have a community of players
now and they expect
more when it comes to tactics so when we
added the sparks we changed the skill
tree we added new archetypes for the
heroes or the enemies the new
ingredients like the items we have now
in the game so basically the strategy
and tactics are truly at the center of
the the gameplay it's a big push that
we've made of course we have autofill
options like we had in the past and this
will help the players in case they don't
want to dig too deep
but the autofill will never be as good
as doing it manually and this is
something that we want to teach those
new players as well well i'm so excited
to play thank you for speaking with me
today and telling us more about the game
we are so excited uh it's an incredible
adventure um very proud of what the team
achieved that's for sure
and uh we i guess we cannot wait to
reveal more but we'll watch out i'm not
spoiling too much let's move here of
course all right well mario plus ravi's
sparks of hope is coming to nintendo
switch on october 20. thanks for
watching
[Music]
was hit hard
here liv
server room identified perimeter bridge
over
[Music]
i'm going in
[Music]
my turn
what's going on
what the
this
impossible
micro recon drums
cute
you forgot this
[Music]
the data key
on your jugular
you were saying
what was on that server
qcr shipment records question is
who wants eyes on it
and why
peggy 18.
hello everyone and welcome to ubisoft
forward we're here backstage and we've
got a great pre-show coming up with
updates on a bunch of fan favorite games
before we kick off the main show
absolutely and if you want to find out
the latest about the world of mario plus
rabbids sparks of hope or get ready to
sail the high seas in skull bones stick
with us as you're already in the right
place and that's not all as today's show
is available in 11 languages four sign
languages and two audio descriptions
head over to the link below to find out
more now on with the pre-show let's dive
into some news and updates on games
you're already playing starting with
brawlhalla where an exciting new
character is joining the fight
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
the ubisoft game makers podcast is back
for a new season and with a new name the
10th art this fall we're inviting
ubisoft developers and some special
guests from beyond ubisoft to explore
video games and their place in pop
culture and society the beauty of video
games and science bringing them together
is that we're bringing research or
bringing science to society and i think
that's really important the relationship
between science and video games or how
fashion and games influence each other
or whether anything can be a game check
out the 10th art today wherever you get
your podcasts listen to our previous
episodes and make sure you subscribe so
you don't miss any of our new releases
[Music]
hey you
yeah you sitting in front of this screen
i see you all
you stuck on a quest looking for that
blasted door key
or you in the back
always looking for new ways to dominate
online in multiplayer matches
well today's your lucky day because now
you can visit ubisoft game plan for
guides walk throughs collaborations with
your favorite creators and exclusive
tips curated by the developers
themselves all of this is created to
help you get the most out of your game
whether it's brand spanking new or a
seasoned classic
find game plan on youtube in game and
online to gain the confidence of an
assassin and the skill of a champion
level operator
as a child
i was taught never to fear the dark
to face my enemies with gritted teeth
and a steady grip on my blade
but now
my hands tremble
something has awakened in the mire
glowing eyes watching the night
shadows slither through the woods
and twisted gackles taunt us
brave samurai venture into the swamps
but what comes back
it isn't them
a deadly web has been woven and there is
no escape
my teachings were wrong
only fools
don't fear the dark
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're just joining us you're
watching the ubisoft forward pre-show in
just a little bit we'll have more
exciting news and trailers about our
upcoming releases to share with you
before we get to this amazing lineup we
still have a couple more announcements
check this out shall we let's do it
hello everyone
at ubisoft for many years now we've been
working with indie studios from across
the world there's been mentoring there's
been funding there's been awards but
above all there's been some strong ties
and learnings from both sides
and today
we're super thrilled to showcase some
game from studios we've had the
privilege of working with
enjoy
oh hi there i'm miko i'm one of the
founders of skyward entertainment we are
a brand new game company based here in
helsinki finland we are currently
working on a game called second stone it
will be a nostalgic mashup combining
your back to the roots classic action
rpg with super tight platforming
gameplay in second stone players will be
drawn into this vast and beautiful world
filled with adventure and excitement
however everything is not as it seems
there is a dark twisted parallel
universe that hides right in front of
your eyes and only you can get there
you will experience a thrilling and
mind-bending story that unravels these
secrets of this hidden realm one piece
at a time to make your journey as fun as
possible in second stone we are working
really hard in perfecting the gameplay
with satisfying tactical combat combined
with state-of-the-art character
progression systems early in development
we were lucky enough to meet with the
amazing people at ubisoft's open
innovation team
they have supported us in many ways for
instance by providing a very detailed
and professional review of our game
pitch and demo this helped us
tremendously in taking second stone
towards the right direction already like
early on thank you all for watching and
please feel free to join us at skyward
entertainment.com for more second stone
[Music]
hello my name is kim and i'm the ceo of
unreliable narrators a montreal-based
studio dedicated to creating games that
empower the voices of those that too
often go unheard we're currently hard at
work on our very first project a
narrative driven game set in 17th
century canada called two falls two sets
of tracks
fresh ones
we're incredibly lucky to be in montreal
where ubisoft has been well established
for now 25 years and a very active force
in the gaming ecosystem and we're really
happy to have won the national bank
favorites award at the ubisoft montreal
indie series we also got marketing
business and technical advice on the
ubisoft entrepreneur division what have
you done to our home tu falls is a game
of contrasting perspective
players will experience the
undertwinging journeys of zhan a
shipwrecked girl stranded far from the
french colonies and maikan a young inu
whose people have become afflicted by a
strange illness as the name of our
studio suggests nothing is quite as
obvious as it seems in our work
through branching and impactful dialogue
options light investigation mechanics
and wonder at the world around them
players will piece together the
mysteries surrounding our two characters
two falls is currently set to release on
pc in the fall of 2023 if you want to
know more about two falls please
wishlist a game on steam or give us a
follow on twitter thank you so much
oh and by the way that's not all
starting right now
you can play indie games on ubisoft plus
our subscription service and it just so
happens to be free to try this month so
go ahead and check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's how i was like trying to think of
how to put in the words is like
if
you're going to do something
what
you're going to do is fully commit and
even if you have a bad year you gotta
double down
once again
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
hello everyone motorflix welcomes you
back to the dominion
after your incredible experience
alongside the forsberg team prepare to
enjoy a whole new episode
get ready to face a winter of fury
performance driving on all terrains
that's how things move this season
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
to enjoy a whole new episode the
dominion frozen
1986 britney france the gemo brothers
launched ubisoft no internet only
creative minds ready to shape the future
of entertainment today ubisoft still
needs talented people to create the
unknown and pierre is one of them
meet pierre
hello pierre is the kind of person who
lives his passion to the fullest
when the first assassin's creed game
came out in 2007 he knew it could
develop into a passion and become a
major part of his life and at first he
wondered if he should take the leap of
faith indeed when i get passionate i
throw myself 100 into things so i'd
rather think twice in the end he did and
ac pierre and ubisoft would go on quite
an adventure together
here is the story piel didn't hop on the
ac bandwagon immediately it was a
trailer that got him hooked no not this
one
not this one either
still wrong it was a fun night trailer
in 2010.
[Music]
serious hooded man watches from a
distance i watched it and then i
immediately showed up at my neighbors
and i play ac all night
he instantly became a fan of ac he loved
the story he loved the aesthetic the
universe he'd never traveled that much
with any other game and pierre has a
passion for cosplay he crafts and wears
beautiful costumes based on the
fictional worlds he loves
so he saw huge potential the universe of
ac was a playground in which i started
to feel very creative cosplay is really
diminding and as every patient sharing
it with others is the biggest reward
pierre was one of the first ever in
france to cosplay assassin's creed
these creations and his presence at
events around the world quickly earned
pierre a growing audience within the
community
he never missed an opportunity to meet
up with people who shared his passion he
did miss the chance to get an ac hoodie
at gamescom one year he never forgot
about that we'll come back to that
hoodie later cair's dedication put him
on the radar at ubisoft so they sent
cosplay kits with top secret unreleased
character details giving pierre the time
to make new costumes before game reveals
that's quite a lot of trust and a lot of
ndas
that said
we
never lived anything
affirmative
it's quite a lot of trust
at this stage his passion had evolved
into a lifestyle pierre was stuck on ac
and ac was literally stuck on him he
wrote and shot a whole web series he
organized fan events where he
orchestrated quizzes and contests
he never missed an opportunity do you
remember eve oh yes i remember
ubisoft wants a community ambassador at
e3 in los angeles
clear the way people here comes pierre
it was a dream come true
i met more more people many from ubisoft
and i finally felt like my commitment
was recognized
at this point pierre had unlocked every
challenge as a player and a community
leader what achievement could he try to
earn next
cair had a new dream to be part of the
teams at ubisoft bringing ac to life
over seven years and five applications
he tried to join ubisoft he waited and
hoped never losing sight of his goal
that's a very long time pierre what kept
you motivated
[Music]
well i had a bit of perspective and
explored new things that i stayed
positive and passionate
[Applause]
positivity and perspective are great
pierre sometimes you just have to put
good energy out in the world and hope it
comes back
right john
wow that's pretty deep
i knew pierre as a community leader for
years so when a position opened in my
team to grow the community leaders
activity pierre were the perfect fit
and that's how pierre's dream came true
he finally joined ubisoft today pierre
is a project manager in the advocacy
team i build bridges and relationships
between the ubisoft brands and the fans
since joining ubisoft pierre has of
course found a new way of building
community around another one of his
passions light i mean laser savers
but the circle cannot be complete
without this slight but significant
detail
you remember this one as his first
manager when we changed job and we were
no longer working together i wanted to
give him a reward for everything he has
done for both ubisoft and our
communities
what else can we say well i do
appreciate the company so you should
come and join us
before i go did you like this story head
over to
jobs.ubisoft.com to hear more just like
this one and maybe even take your first
step towards creating the unknown with
ubisoft
and by the way happy birthday assassins
if you're just joining us you're
watching the ubisoft board pre-show in
just a little bit we'll have trailers
and announcements about your most
anticipated titles to share with you but
before we get to mario plus rapid sparks
of hope and skull and bones we still
have a couple of our announcements to
share with you check it out
hey everyone we are from the annual team
based on ubisoft mainz creators of the
beloved annual city builder series our
latest title anno 1800 transports you to
the age of industrialization
it challenges you to build grand cities
manage a complex economic system and
logistical network and deal with
competitors through diplomacy or
military means
use your fleet to settle on multiple
islands create trade routes and expand
your empire in different regions
in our current season four we're
expanding the new world region of anu
1800 with new content and stories as
well as standalone scenarios for special
challenges
our new world rising dlc will complete
that expansion with an additional
population tier new production chains a
grand monument and new islands to
explore we're very excited to share with
you a first glimpse at our upcoming con
today so
check out this first teaser and make
sure to visit the annie union website
for more info
[Music]
[Applause]
we've all been there
in the midst of battle
at the heart of the race
on top of the highest mountain
or just exploring
[Music]
but some of us
feel the need to stop and capture the
moment
to get
that
perfect shot
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
i'm turning dreams into reality
[Music]
[Music]
what do you need to get your parachute
uh i need 550 radar looking things
do you have any skill points yes i have
three
all right
so let's find you
guys let's get to this area
what the [ __ ] happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are in good shape and jr
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh you're not the bad guy oh you're the
bad guys
hang on i'm trying to be real
oh my god the farmer just ran over the
hostages
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right that's all the updates we had
for you on the pre-show yousef want to
hear some good news oh i sure do all the
games you've just seen in the pre-show
you can try them for free on pc starting
right now for a month on ubisoft plus i
like the sound of free now don't run off
and start playing just yet it's time for
our main show you won't want to miss
this so let's kick things off in style
and get the party started
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hi everybody thank you so much for
tuning in to the september edition of
ubisoft forward the showcase where you
get a taste of all the great things
we're cooking up i'm one of your hosts
neelam kumar i'm yousef mcgee and i'm so
happy to be here today because this year
we're global streaming in no less than
11 different languages so a big hello to
everyone around the world we're also
live in four sign languages and two
audio descriptions so we got you all
covered yo mila i love this studio i
feel like we're big time now come a long
way from being interns i mean look at us
hey
look at us look at us who would have
thought not me but let's get to the real
reason why we're here today games if you
caught the ubisoft board pre-show you
should already be caught up on some
super exciting updates from current
releases and now in the next few minutes
we'll show you what you can expect from
our live and upcoming games concluding
with a very special assassin's creed
showcase in fact let's check in with
them right now
well hello everyone stay tuned for the
assassin's creed showcase coming up
later in the show we'll celebrate the
15th anniversary of this amazing
franchise and share the future of
assassins creed so don't go anywhere
we'll be back soon
we'll be catching up with the assassin's
creed crew later in the show but we also
wanted to remind you that right now
you're all eligible for a three-month
subscription of ubisoft plus giving you
access to some of our best games for
more information check the details on
the screen below and now on to the games
that's right and what a better way to
start the show than by diving straight
into the colorful world of mario and the
rapids this latest adventure mario plus
rabbit's sparks of hope is set to
release on october 20th on nintendo
switch before we catch up with the
game's creative director davide soliani
let's take a quick look
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
a few months ago we gave you an
exclusive on mario plus rabbids sparks
of all
showcasing the game's unique mix of
turn-based combat
real-time action
and open exploration
we also did a deep dive on our unique
team of heroes i want to thank you so
much for your tremendous feedback
and i know
you now want to see more gameplay
so today we are back to show you for the
very first time a first look at one of
the quests from the game
including the special battle that we
took great pleasure
in crafting
hello everyone i'm faye associate
producer welcome to this new video about
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope
today our heroes travel to terraflora in
their quest to save the sparks
this green and usually flurry planet is
struck by a drought caused by curses
malevolent influence
[Music]
go now
[Music]
to help the planet blossom again mario
and his friends must reach the top of
the volcano to get there they will have
to find their way to the central station
and take the wiggler train
terror flora like all the planets of
mario prescribed sparks of hope is
packed with secrets collectibles to
gather puzzles to solve and wacky end
pieces to talk with
with the help of people heroes can
interact with the environment in various
ways to uncover secrets or reveal hidden
paths to new zones
there are many interesting places to
visit and secrets to discover on
terraflora
giant trees lush plains and hidden caves
but let's get back on track
we have a train to catch
[Music]
all aboard
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hmm
[Music]
the revere has been enraged by cursa and
we must stop it before it destroys the
train
mario and his friends will face numerous
enemy archetypes on the battlefield each
with specific strengths and weaknesses
we need to prepare accordingly
let's speak bowser first his huge health
stats will allow him to sustain heavy
damage
rabbit rosalina's signature technique
will be key to neutralize enemies while
the other heroes focus on the darkness
eyes will keep mario and the team to
take advantage of his great mobility
skills
now the sparks there are dozens of
sparks you can pair with your heroes
they will grant elemental damage
resistances help control battlefield and
much more heathering will help robert
rosalina getting behind enemy lines to
wreak havoc
we're done prepping so now is the time
to fight
let's activate mario spark aquanox to
gain additional splash damage
thanks to the splash effect mario can
push the ooze out of the train while he
destroyed the electric barrel with his
second attack
[Music]
rabbit rosalina can finish the ooze off
[Music]
while bowser takes advantage of the
large attack radius of his bouzouka to
destroy two darkness eyes at the same
time
fast forward new enemies are spawning
behind us
we must get rid of them quickly
let's use mario spark glitter to lure
those enemies out into the open before
triggering mario's signature abilities
hero side
[Music]
it's time for bowser to get his revenge
his landing damage ability
combined with the devastating power of
zephyr break his chocolate spark and
mario's support fire will make short
work of this group of enemies
teamwork and synergies are key to gain
the upper hand in battle
now that the back of the train is clear
we must reach the locomotive to destroy
the darkness eyes on the wiggler's back
this won't be easy as the lone wolves
will react by shooting any moving hero
coming into range
they inflict heavy damage to bowser
thankfully exospheres his shield spark
absorbs some of the damage
[Music]
brute force won't make it here it's time
for a stealthy move with rarity rosalina
her spark ethering can turn her
invisible allowing her to approach the
lone wolf safely
now that we are close to them we can use
the signature technique and neutralize
them momentarily
this will allow mario to approach safely
and focus on the darkness eyes
[Music]
a few more turns have passed only two
darkness eyes remain but new powerful
enemies have spawned and even bowser
cannot withstand their powerful attacks
we have only two heroes left and the
last darkness eyes are far out of attack
range
but mario can count on his iconic stump
attack and jump from one enemy to the
other before delivering the final blow
this is it the wiggler is defeated and
our heroes can resume their journey i
hope you enjoyed this very special
battle that's all for now
i hope you also enjoyed seeing an old
friend from nintendo in there
this was only a first taste of our new
take on combat it has intuitive gameplay
with huge tactical possibilities
thanks to the multiple combination of
sparks and ingredients available in the
game
anyone can create combos as marvelous as
they are powerful
the release is almost there and we are
hard at work to polish our game and
deliver the best mario plus rabbits
experience on october 20.
we cannot wait for you all to discover
this brand new adventure
and that's not all
we have one more big thing to reveal
this cosmic journey will not stop at
lunch we have so many wild ideas that we
want to explore in the coming year it is
a bit early to announce all of it
but i couldn't resist to give you a
small peak of what is to come
our post-launch plans include three dlcs
and the third one
will even introduce a new special
playable ear
for me as a creator and for many at the
studio it's a dream come true to have
him
going in an adventure with our dear
rabbit heroes
[Music]
i hope you will like the biggest
surprise of our season pass
thank you
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i love the rabbits and i love the world
of mario and i'm so glad to see them
teaming up once again davide is so
passionate about what he creates and i
can't wait to play his rayman on my team
in this new dlc adventure if you like
what you just saw and want to dive into
the conversations online just use
hashtag ubforward it's up there on the
screen
now back in july we revealed the new
direction of skull and bones and since
then the team at ubisoft singapore has
been hard at work getting the game ready
for launch let's take a deep dive into
the world of skull and bones
the end of the 17th century
when ruthless corporations ruled the
seas with an iron fist
they ignited a battle for global
supremacy to dominate the world's most
valuable trade routes
a flood of exotic goods from the indian
ocean stormed the west
creating new addictions
and a violent race for control
and where there's blood
there are predators
as enemies of all mankind
this new breed of pirates will show no
mercy
sailing through dangerous waters they
created secret trading networks and
built their pirate empires
but they were always on the edge of
losing it all
and sinking to the depths
the skull and bones
will you sing to the bottom or climb to
the very top in the dangerous world of
scandals everything around you is either
your prey or you don't fall
this is where you and your friends will
have an authentic parrot experience
in our game as your infamy begins to
spread across the indian ocean you will
gain access to your own parade lair
known as the helm
here you'll kickstart your stand as a
parrot kingpin by manufacturing and
smuggling illegal and high value goods
to sell to the highest bidder
no longer taking orders from other
parrots you'll now be the one calling
the shots but with all the riches now
for you taking you'll also have more to
lose so beware the vultures are circling
abiding their time to strike you down
will you fend off parrot rogues eyeing
your cargo as you extract your control
bond or undone rivals who want a piece
of your pie maybe you'll plant their
forts for their stockpiles and flood the
black markets or even go on treasurers
to dig up valuable hidden stashes we've
been gathering your feedbacks through
our insider programs and other channels
it's an ongoing process that helps us
shape skull and bones here is what some
of our participants have to say about
the program
greetings pirates captain flynn here my
name's sam more commonly known as mr
stainless i'm bill dane i'm fuzzy boy my
name is spammers my name is hippotc my
name is
this is
charging charlie crispy tater tot here i
joined the skull and bones inside the
program back in 2021 i've actually been
part of the insider program ever since
its inception i've sailed blundered and
pillaged my way through multiple testing
and feedback sessions the play tests
that i've been doing have been a lot of
fun one of the things that i enjoy about
it the most is the streamlined feedback
actually reaching the developers the
developers are passionate about this
game i get to connect with other gamers
who are just as passionate and excited
about skull bones as i am happy to see
the game being revealed again i'm so
excited we're just months away i look
forward to seeing your sales out there i
truly think there's something for
everyone so i'm really eager to see all
the polish and final versions of things
brought into the game i just can't wait
to see all the in the oceans and i'm
really looking forward to seeing all of
you out on the high seas be it friend or
foe
a parrot's work is never done
as your fleet grows so will our game
as in the parrot tales of old you will
always find a ship at the center of the
story one so terrifying that most will
fly on site
that is what we want for our parrots
your ship is your entire world it is
where your success will be decided and
how you will be recognized
in skull and bones to build a unique
ship that inspires fear onto your
enemies
there are three steps
step one pick your weapons and ammo
this will make or break your battles
from pursuing ammo that ignores armor
and causes flooding to tearing armor
that rips your enemy cells apart slowing
them down for an easy kill
my favorite is crushing at it deals a
devastating blow to most armor step 2
choose your armor with our games weapon
counter system there will be an armor
that can counter each damage type that's
how we keep tension high at sea
lastly it's the look of your ship put on
your scariest war paint and head out
with a sheep that is instantly
organizable making this quick adjustment
will transform you from sneaky smugglers
to hard eating hunters or swift traders
now when you are out in the open sea
it's always best to have a friend or two
to watch your back
in our pvp world you can choose to
switch off pvp to prevent any friendly
fire as well
lastly
our game will be cross players lunch so
you can parat with your friends no
matter what platform they are on
ultin then bon voyage and see you all
soon on the seas of scotland bones
this could be the greatest heist ever
[Music]
and you kali will play the villain
ready your ship
[Music]
guard your loins
and seize that [ __ ] convoy
destiny is calling
and our names on our lips
i can't wait to get on my own pirate
ship explore the indian ocean and hunt
you down and steal all your loot gee i
love you too it's out of love it's not a
love skill and films were released this
year on xbox series ps5 and pc all right
we're on to the next title
rider's republic is our massively
multi-player outdoor sports game where
players mountain bike snowboard ski and
wingsuit in epic races and awesome
freestyle events but you know what neil
just we thought it couldn't get any
better we've added an exciting piece of
new content take a look at this
[Music]
[Music]
credit
writer's republic season 4 and the bmx
add-on launches in just four days on
september 14th and guess what you can
play writer's republic for free on all
platforms details are below
now it's time to put the spotlight on
one of our most successful online action
role-playing games yep it's time to
catch up on the world of tom clancy's
the division
hello everyone i'm daria elena community
developer for tom clancy the division
two after more than three years tom
clancy's division two is still releasing
new content and we have exciting times
ahead to recap season nine hidden
alliance brought you so much more than
just a continuation of the story we
introduced countdown an all-new
eight-player pve and game mode plus the
brand new progression feature expertise
giving you new ways to progress your
agent and further increase build variety
and viability
and it's not over the division 2 is
scheduled to receive two more major
updates this year season 10 and season
11.
you will be able to enjoy season 10
price power in just a few days
it will introduce additional difficulty
modes for countdown to push your squad
to the limit add an array of
long-awaited quality of life changes and
set you on the path to uncover the
growing alliance between natalia
sokolova and general anderson and when
it comes to ensuring your agent looks
the best for the new manhunt we've got
you covered
shea paragon and dark path april events
are packed with a variety of new outfits
and vanity to give your agent a unique
look to close out 2022 for the division
2 season 11 will continue the diversion
story not only introducing new manhunt
targets but also some familiar faces and
a new ally it will also feature a brand
new pve mode expanding the variety of
activities and playability in the game
we'll share more details about all these
features later this year
now we want to retariate our commitment
to the long-term future of the division
2 which is fully supported by our
talented developers from ubisoft teams
across the globe with this in mind we're
happy to announce that we are committed
to and have started working on the
division year five
the future is pride for the division two
and for the division franchise as a
whole
now i'll hand over to carrie to
introduce you to tom clancy the
divisions heartland
over the last few years the team at red
storm entertainment has been hard at
work creating an all new experience set
in the world of the division you've
already rebuilt operations in manhattan
you've responded to the call in
washington dc and now you're needed in
the small town of silver creek right in
the heartland of america
today we're excited to share a first
look at the game and some updates from
our studio here's our creative director
keith evans to tell you a little bit on
what to expect in the division heartland
hey everyone we're so excited to show
you heartland an all-new stand-alone
adventure in the division universe
the teams poured their heart into this
game and we can't wait to share with you
[Music]
welcome to silver creek
i'm keith evans creative director in
heartland at redstorm entertainment
we've been involved here at redstorm
with the division going back before the
first game launched our partnership with
massive entertainment made some games
that we love we're so excited to bring
something new to fans of the franchise
heartland's a free-to-play survival
action shooter set in the division
universe that features streamlined
survival gameplay and a beautiful new
world to explore
you play as a division agent given the
task of protecting silver creek a small
town in middle america from enemy
factions rogue agents and a deadly
contamination this game ties directly
into the timeline and introduces all new
characters and story lines to the
franchise
heartland feels fresh and distinct while
still feeling at home alongside the
other amazing games in this universe
we can't wait to have you join us in
silver creek
follow the official division social
channels to learn more about the journey
the team has taken and the important
role of player feedback in the evolution
of the heartland experience and register
now for upcoming tests at the division
thedivisionheartland.com
finally a few weeks ago we welcomed a
new entrance in the division franchise
on mobile the division resurgence this
new opus brings the acclaimed aaa
experience to mobile with the addition
of a new story line factions and much
more
the team is hard at work preparing what
comes next so it is our great pleasure
to be able to give you an update on the
game we wanted to take a moment to thank
everyone who has participated in the
closed alpha playing solo or cooperating
with others to complete a taste of the
game's unique campaign and open world
activities your feedback has been
priceless as we keep fine-tuning and
improving the game today we're happy to
announce that a closed beta test is
coming this fall
this will be an opportunity to play the
iconic conflict pvp modes and for the
first time on mobile the dark zone
we leave you with a look at the trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we're super excited to see the dark zone
coming to mobile if you want to get a
chance to test it out don't forget to
register now on the resurgence website
oof i want that sweet sweet multiplayer
action in the palm of my hands speaking
of which there's another iconic
multiplayer game that was recently
announced rainbow six mobile let's take
a quick look at what the dev team have
in store for us following their
successful closed alpha test
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone i'm justin swann creative
director of rainbow six mobile
it's been a big exciting year for our
game with the worldwide announcement and
our first close alpha taking place
earlier this year it was amazing finally
getting to see how our players and
community reacted to the game and we
couldn't be happier with the initial
feedback
rainbow six mobile is a free-to-play
game designed from the ground up
specifically for mobile devices when we
started production our objective was
crystal clear to bring the rainbow six
universe to the mobile platform and
allow more people than ever before from
all around the world to enjoy this
competitive tactical and team-based fps
experience
our mission is to develop the best
rainbow six experience possible on
mobile and we can only do that with your
help
the dev team and i first want to thank
our community for all your support and
feedback during our close alpha
we took that feedback to heart and we've
made many improvements and it's not just
the core gameplay but our menu systems
and user experience matchmaking and
roundaround flow and many other
adjustments that will improve the
overall experience
all thanks to you and now today
i'm very happy to announce that we are
entering a new phase for rainbow six
mobile the beta test
the closed beta starts this monday
september 12th and the good news is that
android users can still pre-register on
google play for a chance to participate
just a quick note for our ios users
don't worry we are working hard on our
ios version and you will hear from us in
the near future for upcoming tests
so what can you expect to see in the
game during the beta test
our biggest addition is the first stage
of our operator unlock and progression
system this means daily challenges to
complete a ticket system to play with
and unlock your operators and even a
battle pass to progress through on top
of that we have some great graphical and
gameplay improvements social features
like voice chat and persistent teams and
a more streamlined menu flow you will
also be able to compete in three iconic
rainbow six maps
bank
border and the newly added clubhouse
keep in mind this is still a work in
progress version of the game graph
quality and content are much improved
from our alpha test but still not final
as we continue along this exciting road
to release we must move forward
alongside you our players and fans we
believe this is the only way to deliver
the best game experience possible and we
are dedicated to developing rainbow six
mobile in as transparent and
collaborative way as possible with our
players
now
you may be wondering in which countries
the closed beta will be available
starting this monday
well you'll find the answers in this
next video
thank you for all your support and see
you in the closed beta
[Music]
it's the time for anything
i'm ready
[Music]
back
[Music]
[Music]
the rainbow six mobile closed beta
starts on september 12th
here at ubisoft we're developing some
world-class partnerships with some very
big players in the industry here to tell
you a little bit more about it is a very
special guest
hi i'm mike perdue from netflix as you
know we've started to offer a selection
of mobile games on our service and today
i'm excited to announce our partnership
with ubisoft to continue bringing great
games for players all around the world
over the next few years
not one not two
but three games from ubisoft's most
beloved franchises will become
exclusively available to netflix members
the first game is valiant hearts 2 a
sequel to the award-winning first game
directed by the original core team and
available to play in january 2023
next up
the second installment of mighty quest
also coming to netflix in 2023 and last
but certainly not least
fans of assassin's creed will be able to
immerse themselves in the assassin's
creed universe
through both a live action series and an
original mobile game
we'll be sharing more details on each of
these titles as we get closer to launch
the games will be ads free with no
in-app purchases and you'll find them on
the netflix mobile app
thank you to the ubisoft team for their
partnership and we're looking forward to
bringing these great games to existing
and new fans alike
ubisoft and netflix now that's something
to celebrate
and speaking of having something to
celebrate the next project shows how
video games have grown we don't just
play them we make movies based on them
and sometimes tv shows about making them
and on that note let's take a sneak peek
at season three of mythicquest hello
everyone at ubisoft forward i'm rob
mcelhenny writer co-creator and star of
mythicquest on apple tv plus for those
of you who've seen the show we can't
wait for you to watch season three for
those of you who haven't seen
mythicquest this is the series for you
it's a show about a fake gaming company
making a fake game but produced by a
real gaming company that makes real game
elements for our fake game not to
mention we have actors like ashley birch
who are real gaming professionals even
though they play fake characters
you know what why don't you just watch
this teaser for season three it'll
explain everything a lot better than i
just did and in case you're wondering no
you don't need any new gear to watch
apple tv plus you can literally watch it
on the same gaming console you play on
hope you enjoy
this is where the magic happens this is
my legacy our legacy i don't like to see
whatever it's not my like i see where
are we with the expansion let's just be
reasonable adults no something bad is
gonna happen
we'll get you into programming school
local mq will pay for it i think i gotta
go to berkeley yeah that's impossible
no more mr nice guy go ahead and cuff me
oh my god did i miss something we're
leaving you and mythicquest no yes no
yes yes
[Music]
now
let's talk about
our future
this is my dream
we really didn't we just made
50
million dollars
no
what we're not
gonna take the money
yes
i'm glad you're back you know as janitor
i see a lot of things but you have
nothing to worry about there's nothing
like strange or nefarious going on
and even if there was you'd never know
it um sorry wait what are you into the
metaverse hell yeah
poppy where are you
you're the one that didn't want lines
anywhere in the office lines are so web
one you don't want to be in web one do
you you gotta think big
hey pop
can everyone stop sneaking up on me i've
been standing here alone for the last 20
minutes
we're
explorers
innovators
creators it doesn't matter what i
believe about myself
what matters is what you believe about
yourself this
is the year of brittle's base
there's some buttons hello
no buttons anywhere help
ah
[Music]
every morning there's a halo
pretty good every morning
i really love mythicquest i'm so happy
the show got renewed for a season three
same here whether you've played every
ubisoft game in existence or more of a
casual fan there's something for
everyone here at ubisoft forward which
brings us to a very special offer that
we definitely haven't referenced before
check this out
what if we told you that ubisoft makes
the games you know and love
and that's only the beginning of so much
more it is all the assassin's creed
titles even
jump into competitive shooters to test
your skills and your patience team up
for co-op and tactical games where the
only way forward is together
question your definition of good and
evil with some of the greatest villains
in gaming
plan build and create new worlds with
anno and the settlers
game night you don't have to worry about
tables being flipped
need an adrenaline rush
no need for tickets or insurance here
and you thought ubisoft only made open
worlds
[Music]
and guess what try it all for free
starting now until october 10th hours in
hours of gameplay and more being added
every month with indie games and skull
and bones available day one
ubisoft plus is available on pc laptop
and mobile devices try it now for free
at ubisoftplus.com
what an offer a free one-month trial to
ubisoft plus where you can enjoy playing
some of our best games details as always
are below neelam you can fit a lot of
free games into one month you sure can
so be sure to sign up right now
next up we have an update that i know
trackmania fans are going to be excited
about we think you're really going to
like this next trailer check it out
so
ladies and gentlemen
the race
is about to begin
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm augustana davita producer on
trackmania at ubisoft nadio
to the excitement of its 10 million fans
trackmania is back on consoles and
streaming platforms early 2013
and the first bit of good news is that
cosplay and cross progression will be
available across all platforms
ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series stadia and
luna
trackmania is free to play with no
microtransaction but we offer two
premium assets that unlock even more
social and community features you will
still experience that same adrenaline
rush on extraordinary tracks being solo
or online with hundreds of live
opponents
we have lots of features to keep you
racing there's a new seasonal official
campaign every three months
esports events like the cup of the day
with thousands of players
the track of the day which highlights
our players creativity
and you can team up with your friends to
play in the royal or ranked game mods
and that's not all
clarkmania is the best place for
creators to unlock their full
imagination with its industry-leading
and powerful track editor featuring
thousands of blocks and
items after its pc launch two years ago
the game is stronger than ever with 280
000 tracks created by players worldwide
the great news is that these tracks will
be available from day one on the console
and cloud versions
with trackmania clubs we are offering
deep social features within the game
with car skin customization private
rooms as well as campaigns and
competitions organized by the players
for the players
we're looking forward to reuniting the
complete trackmania community in one
single world no matter where and all you
play starting early 2023 welcome to the
club
i love me some track mania i can't wait
to hop online and play against all my
friends i'm sure the both of you will
have a great time well that was
unnecessary
uh moving on let's jam out to our next
release it's for rocksmith plus right oh
sure is neelam if you've ever dreamed of
learning the guitar rocksmith plus is
for you
[Music]
[Music]
neelam i've always wanted to learn how
to play the guitar and i feel like
rocksmith plus is the perfect tool to
get me started well if you're going to
learn guitar you should also practice
your dance moves you mean these dance
moves
how could i forget well for those of you
who like tearing it up on the dance
floor like yousef our next game is right
up your alley this year get ready to
step into a new era of just dance let's
check out all the exciting surprises the
team's been working on
hello everyone i'm claire bourne and i'm
the senior producer on just dance and i
am matthew tomkinson creative director
over the past decade just dance has
become a fan favorite around the world
whether it offers you an instant mood
boost a sense of community a creative
outlet or a way to stay active dancing
is a form of expression that speaks to
everyone
with this in mind our passionate team
has been hard at work on the latest
installment to bring you even more ways
to dance
this year just dance offers a renewed
experience with a new art direction user
interface and unoptimized recommendation
system that find playlists
and songs that fit your every mood
we also invite you to discover brand new
characters and follow them into
immersive stories across rich visual and
musical universes
inspired by the latest hits and all time
classics the game is live at heart and
it will continue to evolve throughout
the year with new songs
new game modes season and much more
there is always something exciting
happening in just dance
for starters for the first time ever in
just dance you can enjoy the new online
multiplayer experience that will allow
you to dance with whoever you want no
matter where they are
with this feature you can create private
groups of up to six people for online
dance sessions
let's check out this new mod together
here is the new homepage of just dance
where you can discover all the
activities the game has to offer
let's welcome our just dancers
[Music]
hello everyone
as you can see you will be able to group
with your friends
interact with them with our new sticker
system
and pick the songs you want to party
along
okay
let's jump into the song if you want a
party
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
great job everyone
let's take a look at the scores
and the winner is helena
well done elena the new score results
screen features the new detailed dancer
cards
of course you will be able to
personalize your own
thanks everyone for joining this session
the first one of many more to come
when you enter just dance you will
always have someone to play with as you
will join one united community
gathered at the same place
we can't wait for you to get your hands
on the game
we'll leave you with the first glimpse
of some of the amazing songs of this
year in the just dance 2023 edition
goodbye
[Music]
any excuse huh i mean it's called just
dance for a reason personally i can't
wait to play with all my friends around
the world and yes neelam i have friends
around the world anyway just dance 2023
adventures launches this holiday season
allowing you to finally dance with your
friends wherever they are on the planet
as you might know 15 years ago we
released a game that changed the world
of video games with assassin's creed we
introduced the new gaming universe
capable of transporting you back to the
crusades as altair took assassinations
to the next level and now thanks to you
15 years later the brand is more alive
than ever this is why we created a deep
dive into the world of assassin's creed
to show you where the brand is going in
the future and we even have several
surprises and announcements for you
and now who better to introduce a
showcase like this than our ceo eve
guimo
[Music]
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for this edition of ubisoft forward
i would like to congratulate all ubisoft
teams around the world for their
tremendous work
bringing these incredible games to life
and to all the players watching us
thank you for the passion you have for
our games creating memorable and unique
experiences is what drives us
every day
speaking of passion for games
we are celebrating 15 years since the
first assassin's creed
altair ezio arno bayek cassandra ever
many of you have lived memorable moments
with these characters
making history your playground
learning challenging yourself and most
importantly having fun
with your support assassin's creed went
beyond a collection of games it helped
shape the face of the video game
industry and became an
for players and developers around the
world
and now
let's see what's next for this fantastic
universe
um
[Music]
so
are you ready for this
of course you are
come on don't be shy
don't let a fancy suit impress you
don't let a thousand fancy suits impress
you
be the thorn in history's side
choose the greatest enemies
the captain
sorry mate
the emperor
the boss's boss
gregory
and make even greater friends
decent work leonardo
don't just pick a fight
and start a revolution
get the bigger picture
go too
far
go too fast
[Applause]
face the invisible
the impossible
the unspeakable
welcome to the greatest playground
history
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome along to the
first ever assassin's creed showcase it
is time to leap into history i'm danny
wallace here in our top secret hideout
where i'll be bringing you some sneak
peeks special guests and sharing some
very exciting updates on all things
assassin's creed you will not want to
miss this today i am joined by a true
expert assassin's creed's senior
community developer ubisoft's own alice
terret welcome to the show alice can you
believe it's been 15 years thank you so
much danny i cannot believe it's been 15
years it's a series very close to my
heart because i'm in it i'm lucky enough
to voice sean hastings who first
appeared back in assassin's creed ii now
sean sounds exactly like me which may
give you a clue as to the limits of my
acting range this year we are
celebrating 15 years since the release
of the first assassins creed
it's been an amazing journey with our
community that started back on the
rooftops of the holy land it has taken
us to the italian renaissance into the
centre of revolutionary wars to ancient
worlds and to many incredible places in
between we've met unforgettable
characters and been to breathtaking
locations allowing you to leap into
history and relive pivotal moments from
our past it's been a phenomenal 15 years
and we are so glad that you came along
for the ride
for the 15-year anniversary of
assassin's creed we want to truly
celebrate with you our community we know
that you've been dying to find out
what's next for assassin's creed and so
uh
just on that point it does sound a lot
like you're about to announce a new game
or something and i am about to announce
a new game i just thought it'd be nice
things i'm here so anyways uh it's time
to discover what we've been crafting in
the shadows i hope you brought a trailer
at least i have roll the trailer
[Music]
are you ready to give up who you once
thought you were i am
[Music]
ready to sacrifice everything your
health
[Music]
are you ready to leave your life behind
and walk the path of shadows
i am
[Music]
then out of the dark you will come into
the light
[Music]
and from the light
you will return to the dark
[Music]
never forget the tenets you have sworn
to uphold
[Music]
stay your blade from the flesh of the
innocent
hide in plain sight
never compromise the brotherhood
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
from this day forward
you are
a hidden one
[Music]
[Music]
well will you look at that assassin's
creed mirage everybody and here to tell
us more it is ubisoft bordeaux's
narrative director sarah bolyer thank
you so much for coming thank you for
having me sarah we just had a little
glimpse of mirage what can you tell us
about this latest and very special
assassin's creed adventure well indeed
it is special we go back to the roots of
the series it's been 15 years as you
know and wanted to go back to the action
adventure game that you know narrative
driven game
we've been focusing on stealth parkour
and of course assassinations
now i've been playing a lot of valhalla
recently and from watching that trailer
i couldn't help but notice bassem
yes you're right it's passive it's 20
years before valhalla so it's a young
vaseem that is going to be
coming from a street thief to a master
assassin oh fantastic and and so where
does his kind of adventure begin
well it begins in baghdad
it's the beautiful magnificent vibrant
city of baghdad that you're gonna roam
through the game and it's um yeah it's a
very dense city where you're gonna meet
a lot of different people that's amazing
i know our community has been very
excited to explore baghdad um so sarah
what can you tell us that makes mirage
special to you specifically well to me
obviously it's all about the story so as
you saw we have a couple of charismatic
characters
starting from basiim so bastian is our
lead character we do have russian that
you spotted in the trailer she's basim's
mentor we also have a lot of historical
characters like in every assassin's
creed so political leaders for example
but not not just
we do have a couple of very very
interesting characters in there well
what a setting and what history to get
your teeth into but we're obviously
about exclusives here
have you got any more yes i do good did
you recognize the voice from the trailer
i did actually can i can i can i reveal
it can i reveal
was the emmy winning actress wasn't it
sorry
it was it was yeah you got it right good
yeah well thrilled to have her in the
cast she's going to be portraying
russian so she's going to be the voice
of bassim's mentor that you serving the
trailer actually and the whole team is
very very glad to have her on she's
fantastic such a recognizable voice
which is why i recognized it of course
well and we were lucky enough to catch
up with shorey earlier and she had this
very special message
hello everyone i am shauryagdoslou and i
am thrilled to announce that i will be
voicing roshan by siem's mentor in
assassin's creed mirage
when ubisoft approached me to voice this
character i was immediately seduced by
roshan's strong personality and her
backstory
she is a true warrior who fights for
justice
and protects her fellow hidden ones at
all costs
she is loyal and honest but keep her
former self behind a shroud of mystery
and of course the fact that she is a
mature woman from persian origins made
her resonate even more with my own story
and background
playing such a character is a unique
opportunity that i could not miss
i hope you will love her as much as i do
it's a real pleasure for me to
collaborate with the assassin's creed
brand and play one of the main
characters in such an anticipated new
game
i am wishing you all a happy ac 15th
anniversary
thank you all
yours
sincerely
what a nice message what a recognizable
voice as well just instantly and she
seems thrilled to be part of this yeah i
think she is really that's good a
welcome addition to the assassin's creed
world so finally
obviously the question everyone wants to
know
when can we get our hands on mirage
assassin's creed mirage is going to be
available in 2023
and if you pre-order now you also get
the exclusive 40 thieves sidequest but
it's not all we also have a collector's
case available for pre-order as well it
includes a figurine of bassim and other
exclusive surprises that you will love
thank you sarah for being with us today
thank you for having me thank you very
much yes it looks fantastic right we'll
be dropping more exclusive news from the
world of assassin's creed very shortly
but first we wanted to celebrate the
last 15 years of assassin's creed with
you let's remind ourselves of some of
the highlights and of course the impact
of this groundbreaking series
out of the dark you come into the light
from the light
you will return to the dark
[Music]
are you prepared to travel the eagle's
path
welcome aboard
it's prizes plunder and adventure ahead
[Music]
we are all different
but our creed
will unify us
[Music]
do you regret your decision to live as
an assassin for so long
i do not remember making that decision
this life
it chose me
[Music]
what is the man but the sum of his
memories
we are the stories we live
the tales we tell ourselves
gentlemen as is custom among our kind
we do not plunge headlong into fully on
the orders of a single madman
but act according to our own
collective madness
from darkness we have come and in
darkness we shall stay
we are
the hidden ones
[Music]
it is a good life we need brother
the best
they never change
[Music]
well so many memories there makes me
want to jump back in and just play
through the whole series again well
danny to continue the celebrations we
also have a new documentary out today
which gives a behind-the-scenes look at
the last 15 years of assassin's creed
let's take a sneak peek
for me assassin's creed represents my
whole
video game in the carrier it's really
like where i learned my job where i grew
in
my job
that was really the game that showed to
me hey you gotta step it up but like you
gotta move on from the ps2 and i fell in
love ever since
university video assassin's creed arrest
is extremely important assassins creed
especially in those early days showing
people what could be done in this kind
of broad open space just like climbing
up things and just looking at this world
and being like oh wow i've never done
this in a video game before we're always
looking for the next assassin's creed no
matter which one is your favorite you'll
always be tied to it because of just how
connected they've kept you in from the
beginning it's not just a game it has
a philosophy behind it it's a universe
it's not just a single setting in a
single time but it's different settings
at different times it's like a narrative
universe that
comes to life
[Music]
well that looks worth a watch to me
where can we see it is it somewhere on
the internet yes it will be on the
internet uh you can catch it on the
ubisoft and gtv youtube channels but
don't go anywhere just yet no so back to
business and i've just finished the dawn
of ragnarok expansion for assassin's
creed valhalla at a great time but i
would like some more yep that's one of
our most ambitious expansions to date
but danny if you want more i've got
great news as we have more content
coming to assassin's creed valhalla
hello everyone i'm gareth glover game
director on assassin's creed valhalla's
post launch
since launch we've continued to create
new and exciting
content for our community
we've already released new game modes
and activities into the world of
valhalla such as river raids tombs of
the fallen mastery challenges and more
recently the roguelite forgotten saga
today i'm excited to announce that in a
few months time we will also be
launching the last chapter so let's take
an exclusive first look
[Music]
odin
i feel you close
[Music]
an uproar of memories stretching far
into the past
i have done all i can for my people
it is time to say goodbye
and set forth for distant shores
and new adventures
fascinating
evil grapples with odin's memories in a
way unfamiliar to me
where will this new conflict take you i
wonder
[Music]
the last chapter is a free questar which
nicely ties up some of the storylines
established throughout the game
we'll see avor reunite with some key
characters including some influential
historical ones
we can't wait for you to experience it
back to you danny and alice
danny are you ready for some more
exclusives no no i'm not no i'm a little
overwhelmed already but please go on
okay well our next guest can do just
that he's no stranger to the assassin's
creed family with a list of credits
including creative director of
assassin's creed syndicate and producer
of assassin's creed odyssey i'm of
course talking about mark alexey cote
mack thanks for joining us well thank
you alice it's great to be here and i i
love what you've done with the place
thank you uh so let's start with our
community can you tell us what makes
assassin's creed so beloved by our
global community well at ubisoft our
mission as a company as expressed by eve
is to enrich the lives of players on
assassin's creed we have a very clear
take on that mission
we want history to be everybody's
playground as we immerse players into
the richness of our shared past
what makes ac different though is this
kind of unique mix between historical
accuracy and contemporary codes like the
animus and when you put all that
together
it gives you the chance to uh embody
iconic characters to live powerful
fantasies all the while immersed in
intriguing uh historical settings it's
amazing uh so how will assassin's creed
evolve in the coming years well we're
going to double down on our passion for
history as we explore the past with
courage
we strongly believe that
history can be the most powerful and
eye-opening source of entertainment
and our teams believe that
history can help us better understand
the world that we live in as so many
elements from the past still resonate
with our present but don't worry we're
gonna keep telling grand epic stories so
that viewers and players alike can feel
the vertigo that only human history can
bring
i love the way you talk about history
and about using history as a playground
what an incredible thing to be able to
use history in this in this way but what
does this mean for fans going forward
well we want our passion for history to
fuel the expansion of the franchise into
new territories so i'm very happy to
announce today our very first open world
assassin's creed game for mobile
it will feature all the iconic
assassin's creed
gamepl for an experience on touch
controls and i just can't wait to tell
you more about the story and the setting
let's take a look at the trailer
[Music]
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
well look at that a brand new assassin's
creed game set in china it looks amazing
uh matt can you tell us a little bit
more about the features
well for the first time in our open
world games you can create your own
character you'll get the chance to do
things like parkour atop the great wall
of china sneak through bustling cities
engage in intense combat and discover
the secrets of vastness of ancient china
well that leads me to my next question
so mac many of us know that a netflix
show is in development and the community
would like to know more what else can
you tell us well it's still early in
development but i can confirm that we
are co-developing the netflix series
with ubisoft film and television netflix
obviously and an insanely talented
showrunner jeb stewart it's going to be
an epic jar bending a live action
adaptation of our video game series but
that's not the only thing we have in
development with netflix we also have a
new mobile game and development for
their platform wow so you're doing quite
a lot with netflix and just out of
interest there's no reason for me to ask
this this is just just curious a lot of
people probably want to know who who is
the casting director for that
why do you want to know no i'm just just
a lot of people have been uh tweeting in
about that well we'll put this name on
screen i'll talk to you after about that
uh in the meantime let's take a look at
the wider world of the saturn's creed
[Music]
well the wider world of assassins creed
there and look we've had a lot of
surprises today i think that's fair to
say but in the grand tradition of
surprises mack i think you might have
saved the biggest one for last well
danny that's right believe it or not
i've got more things to show to you so
how about we take a leap of faith into
the future together let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
well i think that's what you call big
news isn't it i mean there's a lot of
stuff in there that i think from your
point of view certainly the community
the fans have been asking for for a long
time so mac tell us more well this is
code name
red our next premium flagship title and
the future of our open world rpg games
on assassin's creed it is being
developed by ubisoft quebec the studio
behind assassin's creed odyssey under
the creative direction of jonathan zuma
it will let players explore one of their
most awaited settings ever on the
franchise feudal japan and they'll live
a very powerful shinobi fantasy i mean
people have been waiting for this for a
long time haven't they yes they have
they certainly have now you brought it
to them it's amazing which is good and
you're slightly cruel in that you're
teasing me with it i very much want that
you mentioned um some of the other
studios uh what's montreal up to right
now well we have our veteran team behind
assassin's creed valhalla in montreal
the birthplace of assassin's creed who's
been hard at work on a new flagship
title as well it is being led by
creative director clint hawking it is a
very different type of assassin's creed
game and i believe you may have brought
us something that we can watch now yes
here it is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well the surprises just keep on coming
what can you tell us about this project
well this is code name hexay and i can't
wait for our fans to tear apart that
trailer and find out all its secrets
yeah absolutely and work out the code
now you guys have always got code names
for stuff there was um was it a year ago
there was
code name infinity
wary with that well that's a great
question danny and i'm happy to give you
a little bit more about project infinity
today
infinity is not a game per se it's going
to be the single entry point for our
fans into the assassin's creed franchise
into the future so you're saying that
players will be able to explore their
very own animus kind of like a time
machine exactly alice infinity is going
to be a hub that will unite all our
different experiences and our players
together in meaningful ways
so
obviously that begs the question if
you're connecting players and there's
more than one player a lot of people
will be thinking are we talking
multiplayer
well danny it seems we can't hide
anything from you
we're actually investigating how uh we
will bring back standalone multiplayer
experiences into the assassin's creed
universe
all connected to the infinity hub
well it sounds extraordinary you must
have a nap at some point because you've
all been very very busy so our thanks
mack some major new developments there
and i'm sure everyone at home can't wait
to get involved thank you for joining us
today and sharing all this incredibly
exciting news well thank you danny thank
you alice it's been a pleasure to be
here and to be finally able to share all
these great things that we have coming
for our fans
so to sum up there are a lot of exciting
things to look forward to let's remind
ourselves of everything you can expect
from now onwards
this year we will see the release of the
last chapter to aval's story in
assassin's creed valhalla then in 2023
we'll see the release of the next big
title assassin's creed mirage set in
baghdad and following the story of
bassem from street thief to master
assassin
then it's time for the long-awaited
setting of feudal japan with assassin's
creed code name red and as mack
announced there will also be a very
different type of experience with
assassin's creed codename hexe and in
the coming years we'll see the launch of
the new platform assassin's creed
infinity connecting players to the games
in a whole new way but that's not all
we'll also see the launch of our first
open world game for mobile with
assassin's creed codename jade and of
course the release of our live action
series in partnership with netflix so
loads to come but that my friends i'm
afraid is all we have time for today in
this very special assassin's creed
anniversary showcase now before i get
too comfortable in our hideout and end
up slipping into my ezio cosplay as
normal i just want to thank everyone for
joining us today and making this first
ever showcase so special plus of course
a big thank you to our guests and i
shouldn't do this alice but you know in
the spirit
looking forward to that's a very tricky
question we've seen so many amazing
things um i'm gonna pick a few okay i
will choose mirage um the netflix series
and also feudal japan is that okay
that's fine great and for all of you at
home remember that you can pre-order
mirage now in the meantime you can jump
back into valhalla to prepare for aval's
last chapter which is exactly alice what
i'm going to do while we pass back to
ubisoft forward we will see you next
time
bye-bye goodbye
neil that was one hell of a show you can
say that again that was one hell of a
show well that does it for this edition
of ubisoft forward we hope you enjoyed
it yusuf what are you looking forward to
play you know we covered so many great
games today can't wait to play them all
well if you need a reminder of all the
upcoming games featured today head to
our website at ubisoft.com and remember
to grab that free month of ubisoft plus
you won't want to miss it thank you all
for watching around the globe we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
oh
[Music]
going home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you